[Music]
you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes I hear that Bell and I'm ready to
fight Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up
they want the boat they don't work and
no don't mess around and end up hurting
them I say the wrong thing make it
personal you say the wrong thing what is
up fam welcome to the very first UFC 280
fight companion also known as the
Calabasas fight companion but this is
live from Salt Lake City Utah we're at
the Wise Guys Comedy Club we're here in
the green room and I have two very
special guests that flew in just for
this to my right is the living legend
himself maybe you've seen him popping a
few bones back in the day he is UFC
royalties the former heavyweight
champion of the world it is Frank Mayer
and to my left you guys know him from
his Hit YouTube show it's Jesse on fire
Jesse on fire he is just a wealth of
knowledge when it comes to MMA what's up
brother what's up about time we did this
thing dude happy to be here I've won
John for a while Frank you and I were
just together just chatting about some
fights going through all your old fights
and I did your podcast get your boy
Harrison here yep Harrison Rogers came
down and hung out with us so yep
Harrison's my boy now have a a Mormon
friend so be cool everybody
I've run Salt Lake City I didn't know uh
Harrison you should give me the heads up
in Salt Lake City they have all those
gorgeous churches and you can't you know
any other religion you just walk in and
check out the church because you know
you're the same when it comes that's
tough so I I it's interesting I wanted
to go in and just peep it out dude you
have to you got to be Mormon yeah it's a
membership and not just even Mormon a
lot of them you have to be like the
temples and whatnot you have to be uh
certified or ordained or forget the word
I'm looking for uh you know basically
you have to be good enough yeah you'll
be like a five-star Mormon uh they've
got a social credit score yeah that's
pretty cool I respect it come on man
pull your weight what's it called Hey
Harrison what's the what's the password
to get into that freaking Place dude you
know there's a secret handshake too
there is a secret handshake apparently
you can't but if he tells us yeah we'll
go missing
that's Mormon rules well they all they
they all do their mission so like they
go they all go to different places in
the world and go go recruit yeah how
do they decide where you get to go I
don't know because some guys you go to
like Brazil but they're going door door
to door in the favel they open they
literally open it
correct me if I'm incorrect here but
I've heard they open an envelope and
it's like here's where you're going and
then they're like either really excited
you're going to Detroit yeah learn the
language and stuff if they're going
somewhere overseas yeah gee what a beast
I'll tell you what to be so it's rare
I'm this excited for UFC card listen to
pull off this companion on the road he's
an is a beast I have to fly with the kid
shout out to Casey chin we have to fly
out the crew we got the cameras here
from thick boy to beast but this card I
didn't realize because usually if I'm on
the road I'd miss him if I'm on tour I
just miss them but this one's in Abu
Dhabi so it's a 12 uh start mountain
time so I'm like oh we can pull this off
I called you two you guys are in I'm
like you think we're working with
something here yeah if this card was in
this stack there's no way we would have
done a fight companion but this card is
I'll tell you man last night I was like
oh I can't wait I I cannot Maybe
I don't know dude maybe when I'm not
trying to suck you off here but probably
when you Brock Lesnar the first one
because I felt like it was uh MMA versus
you know like you represented all of us
yeah yeah that was like that was funny I
was telling a story a show and my boy
James actually let me know he goes it
was Matt Hughes that came up to me and
said hey man you realize this is you
know MMA versus yeah pro wrestling
that's how we all as he walks off I'm
like no no wait a minute
no he's actually credential wrestling
he's national champion at Minnesota
multiple times here man he's not the
Undertaker dude this is like a legit
freaking wrestler bro he's an
All-American almost like a cat yeah I
wish it was Hulk Hogan out there but
it's not man this guy's a freak but this
card is stacked it's ridiculous now we
did see some of the prelims you know and
to kick it off your boy's over one I
took uh me too Muhammad I absolutely
love you know this dude I'm a Big Sean
Brady uh dick rider he's Philadelphia's
finest this is his toughest test
he got pieced up yeah I mean listen I I
and this isn't a dog on Sean Brady I
wouldn't have picked him if someone's
like yeah he's really just gonna try and
stand with him like what yeah his gift
is on the ground for sure every time he
tried to take below down though he just
shook him off like yeah
so I don't know if it was so much a
decision that he made or but just you
know the guy forced him to go and stay
on his feet and fight him that way
dupilal is nasty though and Jesse you
didn't know that Blau uh training with
khabib get ready no I didn't I would
have bet on him he trained with khabib
before and he uh on food truck he came
on a food truck and he was saying how
how intense khabib is he's like it is no
he's like it was the most intimidating
situation I've ever been in he's like
they're warming up and I was like
waiting to get in but you got to wait
till they invite you he's like he was
like this big like real formal thing
he's like nothing I was used to that
doesn't surprise you at all like when
when when there was a rumor that
rockhold was going to let khabib Coach
him I was like dude if he actually goes
all in and lets khabib run his show he
might actually be able to make a run at
this thing he could but he with rock
holds grappling and Jiu Jitsu is a
nightmare but it's interesting because
all right now khabib's what because his
cousin won right his cousin his cousin
won early on the prelims Muhammad won
yeah I don't know if this is any
indicator in the middle name
yeah we were talking about that I always
thought that when I sit there watch
fights for him the guy I'm fighting has
other teammates on the card guys he's
trained with in the same camp you kind
of keep an eye on him you can't help but
notice for shape yeah how are they doing
with the mentality you know because
there's like a momentum that you can see
getting built you know for sure and then
like just the energy of that it's like
if you see two guys on your team win and
then you're the next guy up in like in
any sport like that it's like uh and I
was actually talking about this
yesterday before these fights where I
was saying that like the kind of you
know Ali abdelazi's crew had like hit a
skid recently kind of like where you
know gaichi lost and uh Kamar lost and
where you know but apparently they've
turned it around
yeah I'm on that flip side too kind of
like I think it kind of eats at your
confidence you're sitting there going
all right unless you know one of your
guys on the team's not that great but
you've sitting there okay we're doing
this we're doing that my guy's good and
also he goes out there gets manhandled
and he's like oh [ __ ] well let me really
think it was through for exactly yeah
you know that doubt starts creeping into
your mind have you been on car train
because I've been on cards where and
you'll see a do this because it's easier
if it's 1K up so in our camp it's like a
super camp Sid like Nate Marquardt
Dwayne rodwig Elliott Marshall
everybody's blue Corner together yeah
they're 12 in the blue corner just make
it easy but when you're the first one
like kick the card off you're like oh
here we go fellas we've all been trying
really hard for this hopefully I don't
let you guys yeah that's an extra
thought that goes through your mind you
sit there and you're going out they're
like all right man let me start this off
oh sorry uh you can start it off uh um
you know get the momentum going get it
going the vibe of the room no one wants
to be in the room when you walk back and
then oh there's always busted up and
just like head down and like ah [ __ ]
because it just kills the mood like it's
hard to have good energy before you guys
walks in just had his ass handed to him
he like walks in goes in the bathroom
he's bleeding all over the place even if
he's not on YouTube team like if you're
in the Red Corner blue corner and the
guy before he gets his ass up or two
fights where he gets his ass up and
comes back to the room like all beat up
it just the morality yeah that you see
the reality that you're in like oh that
could be me oh my God and you can just
see like well you can empathize with her
for sure but you're just like oh and now
I remember when uh Shane was fighting uh
Brock Lesnar I thought Brock Lesnar's
training partner and his best friend so
I was the main event on the prelim Shane
was the main event and Shane was like
get it done you're kicking us off and I
start this you know whatever minute six
knock him out I come back I'm like
that's how we do it but I remember
before our head coach Lisa Ebola was
like okay if you lose don't come back to
the locker room like just like go to the
side go handle your [ __ ] in the bathroom
like don't bring those energies yeah
Shane doesn't need this before Brock
Lesnar that's smart dude yeah [ __ ] dude
he should have won that fight too I mean
like if his he he smashed Brock in the
first round and then he just completely
gassed out and then man I'm surprised I
actually didn't stop the fight you know
yeah I thought they could have stopped
it they could have stopped I mean Brock
at one point
and then but her Dean's credit he did
you know he did come back and see with
him so I was like all right maybe you
shouldn't say yeah that's one thing
someone goes they could have stopped the
fight I'm like I hear you but if the
person comes back and wins like in that
one I would be like all right well it
was a good not to say yeah yeah sure let
me know if you don't stop it then the
guy continues to take a lot of damage
and almost like oh like wow that was a
bad knockout yep okay now yeah you're
right you should have stopped it yeah
like in that Sean Brady one like you
know he was getting beat up he's 10 to
notes his first loss like don't let him
go out on a shield because Sean Brady's
such a tough dude yeah he'll take all
the dance yeah we don't need that as
long as you do got to protect guys from
themselves yeah
like you could just see where he kind of
he turned where
he was hurt well we only turned out I
only started paying attention I think
halfway through the first uh yeah and
you could just see his demeanor his
energy the way he was it's like he was
in survival mode yeah but I was in
hunting mode you know yeah but if you're
going to learn a lot from Sean Brady
because you know with his first kind of
really hiccup in his career he fought
the number five guy in the world maybe
it's too much too soon it was a tough
matchup for him so now you're really
gonna fit in this next fight you're
gonna realize who Sean Brady is yeah
when you're winning these things
this goes with the same with sugar Shawn
yeah with sugar Shawn you know the
criticism on on him which you know I
don't agree with a lot of it but I can
see where people understand it's like he
really haven't found anybody half the
guys that he beat aren't even in the UFC
anymore yeah you know he did lose the
the Cheeto yeah and then he had the
Pedro Munoz hiccup right with the
illegal uh the the eye poke thing there
so he really hasn't passed any tests but
it's like with him and he doesn't
believe those are losses so for him to
fight Peter Yan would you know
I'm just curious what that does to Sugar
yeah yeah I mean the reason why they
made the fight is because they looked at
the they looked at the layout of
bantamweight obviously their goal is to
have O'Malley be the champion and they
look and Peter Yawn is Peter John's like
one year older than them like he's like
I think O'Malley's 27 and Beyond is 28
and they're like okay so there's no way
for him to get to the title without
having to fight Peter Young at some
point Jan's coming off two losses this
is a three-round fight this is literally
our best opportunity to have Sean be
agree again it's like kind of like shoot
her get off the pot with sugar when
people are like oh it's too much too
soon it's like it's been UFC five years
dude yeah it's like yeah for the UFC
they're kind of like like I didn't have
that luxury no no you definitely did
neither I didn't my first actual UFC
fight was against Roy Nelson you know
it's like first open yeah and then six
months later I'm playing Gabriel Gonzaga
it's like there was no warm-ups too so
with sugar Shawn the UFC is like let's
see dude and if he wins
I don't care what happened to the
co-main event Main Event if sugar Sean
wins he's so polarizing his face will be
the he'll be the talk of Yoshi if he
wins by knockout oh nuts
a rocket ship yeah it was like when
Conor knocked out though Aldo hadn't
because the thing where I have a hard
time getting to where he's going to
knock yawn out as I'm like dude I've
never I haven't even seen him get hurt
really like young but that's how Aldo
was and then he Connor starched him yeah
you're right and I actually had I was at
that point I remember laughing at people
that were like oh man Conor is bigger
this that I'm like guys it's Jose Aldo
yes you know what I mean like that guy
like I mean he scalps people with knees
you know I mean like his kicks I mean he
almost paralyzed I mean I thought Urijah
Faber would never walk again like have
you not watched this guy's fights
leading up to that point and then yeah
he just dismantled them so do you do you
think if sugar Sean pulls off like let's
say he gets a knockout over Petron do
you what do you do you think's more
impressive what Conor did to Jose or is
it more impressive what suga's doing to
Peter Young I would say sugar beating
this is a bigger jump in competition
because it let you know because Conor
had to get through uh uh Chad Mendes
right before that when he said short
notice fight but he beat Chad Mendez
right and then he was he was kind of
losing the car the fight he got taken
down right yeah and they had the body
shot but then he also beat uh yeah uh
who was it he made Holloway but that was
before Holloway was still good win and
then he beat uh the Brazilian cat
Poirier yeah so definitely more
impressive for Connor yeah I'd say you
had to go with that one because also too
remember at that point Jose was the
champ yeah man like that he was number
one dominant yeah
whereas right now Beyond I mean even
though I don't agree with it I mean I
think that was the dumbest like I'm
still we're talking about the gym the
other day I'm like why did you do that
dude like it was a one-sided fight there
was no position for you to throw that
knee that was [ __ ] oh yeah in the
first fight yeah so I mean I mean those
were 10-8 rounds a couple of them and
then in his last fight with with
Sterling look besides the two rounds of
Sterling took his back I had Peter young
one in the fight I thought he won I mean
especially the fifth round he was
destroying him the first round I you
know that's obviously deciding around
that the judges gave to Australia but I
thought Peter Young when he was moving
forward throwing more aggressive strikes
trying to throw hard to me the slap and
run I just and that may be just
subjective of my part I don't wave very
heavily into it not that I'm against
running but I'm into running and hurting
people yeah yeah
and if you walked into him he'd put you
on your ass yeah Machina style like okay
you run but like yeah yeah Wonder Boy I
mean but like the whole slap and run and
like well you're not really doing damage
the other guy's not getting hurt but
Frank as a you know Jiu-Jitsu Legend as
far as Al Jermaine having his back for I
mean how long was it yeah it was
impressive would you give those 10-8
but there's no danger so to me almost
it's like well it's like it wasn't like
you were like the guy was screaming you
know like in with the submissions was
like right on the verge or yeah locked
in and he's barely surviving no it's
like he had risk control the whole time
yeah and the body triangle look it's
it's not an easy position to get out of
you got a thin waist and a guy has long
legs like algebra you know they lock it
up it's almost like you just can camp
out there to me it's a very sound Point
strategy to lock it up and not go
anywhere because no referees going to
pull you up but you also not like if
you're if he's still in a body triangle
it's very they're not looking for a
finish it's kind of a neutral position I
mean yeah you can get the Knack with but
you just especially at this level with
Peter John I'll join it's gonna be tough
to get that rear naked joke especially
if the guys is sitting there points me
if you can't get it within two or three
minutes you're not getting it close and
then if you don't let the body triangle
go to train think about if I'm trying to
finish you we're rolling I lock up a
position it's called side control and
I'm not getting nothing you're gonna
transition somewhere else right well I
want to finish you let me find another
spot to try to finish you out you know
if I lock up on your back and I just sit
there and camp out for points it's like
all right well you're trying to
strategically win I don't fault it but
that to me I can't reward 10A for that
mentality yeah it's like okay you're
just holding on to score the win with
the judges now if he would have let go
and transitioned to his to Mountain
transition side and just going
everywhere like all right well [ __ ] you
put a clinic on that's a 10 a round yeah
yeah you're right well hopefully uh if
sugar Sean does win uh he I heard he
might shave his head he's gonna use
manscape that's called a transition
fellas so uh Michael Myers sure is scary
the last thing you need is be hairy this
Halloween Fellers luckily our friends at
manscape launched their fourth
generation performance package make sure
your pumpkins get the ultimate carving
experience on this spooky day there's
gonna be a lot of Halloween references
get ready uh turn your bite-sized treat
to a king-sized candy and join the Six
Million Bros worldwide who trusts
manscape by going to manscape.com for
twinks off and free shipping with the
code shop20 SCH ab20 make the right call
this spooky season it's trick or Tran
bam baby have you ever tried have you
ever tried to trim your balls and turn
into a Freddy Krueger film it's not good
another Halloween reference for you guys
manscape is here to save the day and
make sure you're feeling your best in
your costume you don't want to be a
thick Spider-Man you got your bush
poking through the front scaring the
kids your son's embarrassed of you trim
it down man you do that with the
performance package from the performance
package 4.0 for manscape inside you'll
find the Holy Grail of Men's Grooming
items all right they made it easy for
you to upgrade your grooming routine
it's a full moon out there another
reference Halloween werewolf in your
pants is howling it's time to tackle the
problem with the lawnmower 4.0 we got
you guys the lawnmower 4.0 is the
greatest ball trimmer on the planet also
what else are you going to use just use
it how many times have you heard me do
this read all right it's waterproof it
has a light on if you want to do it at
night if you're embarrassed of your bush
all right the 4.0 package also has the
weed whacker
um the weed whackers the nose and ear
hair trimmer all right we got you with
that they have the crop preserver ball
deodorant the crop reviver to make sure
your balls stay fresh manscape also just
launched a new body buffer this is 100
antibacterial body scrubber the manscape
even threw in free two gifts two free
gifts for you in this performance
package 4.0 you get the boxers and the
shed travel bag all right so if you're
sick of looking like Wolverine and you
haven't cut your nails recently they
also got the sheer 2.0 nail kit again
get twinks off and free shipping with
the code shop20 manscape.com the swim
stuff and free shipping with the code
shop20 atmanscape.com say trick or treat
your beautiful new Halloweeny with
manscaped
dude I'll just add to that that they
also sponsor my channel and that [ __ ]
about you've ever used like a buzzer to
like and it get you know like what
they're saying is like and then and this
doesn't like I was shocked I was like
Jesus
it is a nightmare I don't know what kind
of Technology they got but it does work
you you look like a hairy dude Frank
you're married
no not at all man actually but I still
make sure I trim up and stuff there's
nothing like seeing your lady doing this
[ __ ]
it just interrupts
[Music]
I mean this is a high profile fight you
got the number one Contender it's number
six here I was surprised this was in the
main event on prelims and Sean Brady and
Muhammad were kicked off the main
strategy I think to sell the
pay-per-view like get it get a big fight
as the which they always do so it gets
people crunk you know and then have the
announcers like you better go buy this
thing yep that was a great prelim Main
Event too that was a great fight there's
a lot of decisions on the undercard
which yeah here's the if you're a UFC
fan you guys know this sometimes on
those prelims when they're like
Knockouts the most exciting fights
you've ever seen typically then the main
card is slow totally so it's never the
full card it's very rare so I think by
that being kind of that slow that means
this main cards can be yes do UFC Austin
the show like we went to obviously
because in Austin I think there were
nine Knockouts like it was it was I
think there's a record of uh most
knockouts in a single event it was like
every single fight just knock up
knockout knockout we were like what the
[ __ ] is going on and then the and then
the main event was uh Josh Emmett
against cater which is a five round
slugfest [ __ ] war god Emma's just
chilling huh they still don't know what
they're gonna do with him yeah
he's a good dude what do you do with him
oh It's just tough man you know you're
in this day and age of marketing stuff
like that like you see what they're
doing sugar you see they announced Patty
pamlett's next fight yeah oh yeah he's
fighting his right hand a veteran Gordon
I think he's like 21-7 you know but yeah
I think all his wins are by decision
um you know so it's a step up for Patty
what do you think of uh Paddy's jits
Frank I think it's legitimate I mean
honestly it's the best part of this game
I think it's legitimately good Grappler
you know nogiz and I think he could
apply a little bit better as he figures
it out for the MMA I mean obviously I
mean I think there's more to criticism
to a stand-up you know what I mean in
his wrestling because that's the part
probably you know you have to be the
greatest stand a fighter but if you have
great jits how do you connect it how do
you get it to the ground and uh that's
where I see a kind of a weakness in his
game he's got that they you know hit his
Fame is
is ranked higher than where he's at
right especially at 55 because I'm I'm
telling you I've had a million fighters
on food truck and all that stuff you've
never met someone more electrified more
you just you can tell it's not a gimmick
and whenever you know you're
interviewing a fire they'll talk to you
not him he knows his camera he's like
camera on camera too and he's doing a
promo into the film yeah and I was like
he's just such a good person and like
just such a sweet dude you can't help
alumni oh I get it I get it I like it
but I think too that they got to be
smart you just nailed in a nutshell
they'll be smart with them because I
think his popularity has gotten him in
deeper waters and his fighting abilities
right now you know do I think he can
develop definitely but I think it's too
much too soon to you know to get into
those deep Waters from those guys even
the conversation about all of uh Conor
fight I'm like no please no yeah yeah
that might you know come on man it just
doesn't make any sense either no but uh
but the UFC's learning man you know what
happened with Darren till which is a
tough situation I do think he bounces
back back they've you know they've done
it with uh Uriah Hall you know an
exemption silver and they throw them in
the mix
yeah although garban won the title yeah
but still then just wolf after wolf
after wolf that's how it is a feedback I
know that's something too like sometimes
I wish I understand you have a tough
path up the hill but when you got a guy
that we know is good you should keep him
like giving the guy an easier fight I've
lost not the worst idea I totally let me
get this feedback under him let's give
him and if the other guy does well we
build somebody else up you know but like
you know given the guy just monster
that's what boxing does and the UFC's
yeah yeah they'll be like all right he
really struggled with that let's get him
get his confidence back yeah look at
Wilder while it just starts that dude
but he you know Wilder was in a weird
place you know if he can retire what
he's gonna do and now you know it's Off
to the Races yeah but UFC I will give
him credit they're getting better
because back in the day it was you
better be ready to go man you might you
might you know they're gonna toss you to
a big boy a veteran you probably
shouldn't be in there with you know
trust me it's tough so it should be you
know with the UFC now it's more of a
marathon not a Sprint you know what I'm
saying because these guys were sprinting
and you're out you've seen three years
yeah there's enough there's enough
Fighters now for them to do that too and
if I mean if they're if they're
reflecting like self-reflecting it's
like why do you not have a superstar
right now
probably because you're constantly
throwing everybody to the Wolves agree
yeah and I think too with guys like
sugar Shawn and guys like Patty pimlet
the the landscape has changed too
because I both of these guys Patty Pima
introduction even though he has a new
contract they make most stupid in the
face they make more outside of the Octon
than they do fighting yeah so with Patty
I'm like you know do you do you feel
pressed to fight top 15 he's like no
he's like and I was like because he gets
really big he was like two something
220. I agree with you yeah I was like
dude you got to tighten it up and he and
I go why don't they call you for a short
nose fight it's like a lifetime
opportunities like he started laughing
he's like I would never he's like never
I make too much money outside then find
out I would never take a short nose
fight because it's not happening man she
took that Ferguson fight and it was that
was the correct call he said he would
never take a short notice and then he
the UFC had another announcement UFC's
had a few announcements since I've seen
you both of you so Jesse we talked about
a little bit earlier but uh they
announced which to me it's very
frustrating it's been two years since
he's fought I'd love your take on this
Frank Jon Jones isn't fighting this year
they said probably look you know
probably March or something like that
which is frustrating
um and then they also announced uh uh
um uh Hamza and Kobe Covington that
they're trying to put that together
trying to put that together which is a
phenomenal fight for sure and they want
to do that on the as the co-main on the
uh Camaro and Leon fight which would be
awesome in England yeah and Kamal asked
for the fight in England good yeah
that's gangster actually gangster yeah
what's your thoughts on uh Jones Frank
it's frustrating that he hasn't yeah I
mean I've trained with him and I think
that like honestly if I said he had a
weakness in his style it would be
against speed you know even the few
rounds we've ever seen him lose like
Vegeta and whatnot and even the gym uh
so I think moving up to heavyweight it's
actually a good thing for him because
he's not giving up reach not giving up
strength I mean
ungodly strong I mean like uh it's
slowly just you know ability just to
lock onto you and just not break out of
the grip is unreal yeah yeah uh so you
know he brings with him strength and uh
reach still and and now he's fighting
guys that are slower and and that you
know honestly I think the wrestlers are
probably better at 205 typically than a
lot of the heavyweights are agree so I
think that honestly that he's going to
be just as dominant if not more dominant
and heavyweight that's why once it gets
in there and I think I think he's going
to run the whole thing me too yeah and
anybody that's trained with John
especially as a heavyweight I mean I've
seen him walk through the gamut they
call it Shark Tank where John would stay
in and then a new guy would come in
every round five rounds I won't list the
name of heavyweights that were in there
it was me and some other heavyweights
that we all know he beat the [ __ ] out of
all of them and we were fresh
and he you know he's just he's just a
different animal he's even done things
to me on the ground that I like threw me
off I was like I've never had anybody do
that to me before that's where everyone
I'll get an example yeah I was in his
garden you know I was on top of him he
grabs my wrists he literally just stands
up and pushes me off and held my wrist
and as I stood up I'm like looking at
and then I tried to break his grip and I
had to roll out and by the time I
actually broke the thumb on his grip and
got out he was up I'm just like
I can't even teach that to somebody like
how do you even show that move to
somebody like and he tried the funny
thing is John was like no no you do it
like this I'm like John I think you need
to realize it bro it's easy you just did
that yeah I'm like
there might be some physical limitations
some people are born to do things with
other people you know what I realized is
I this just dawned on me that my
favorite story about Jon Jones I heard
from you on a podcast in 2017 when it
was it was right before he was going to
fight DC the second time and I was
trying to handicap that fight I'm like
[ __ ] man I don't know he's gonna win and
I heard you tell the story that Jon
Jones told you that he had to go to
decision because he had to break DC in
the first in the first fight but that he
was gonna finish him in the second fight
and right there I was like oh he's gonna
win seven he's gonna win yeah I think
though they only did if you watched that
he died
yeah yeah he was broke yeah yeah I think
the only caveat with John at heavyweight
and it listen you could uh chalk it up
to he's just snugging up for the the
fight that light heavyweight there's no
you know people that get him out of bed
and get him go in the morning so he kind
of Coast through those fights even
though he wants them you know the Donald
grace fight was tough for him the the
who else was it the um
Diego Santos was tough for him but he's
still technically won those fights the
only he he gets hit more than he did
before and heavyweight you know in this
range we both know this at heavyweight
you just can't take shots no you can't
especially supposed to be fighting to
Francis assero gone or Curtis blades you
know but I wonder how much of those him
you know with speed you know what I mean
that's why I think that the two of Five
Guys Are quicker and I think that you
know landing on them I mean hell even I
remember watching Victor Belford in
their fight T and I thought yeah because
the speed threw him off yeah you know
obviously once he grabs him so you know
I just don't think he's gonna see that
same speed of 205's or heavyweights I
think that's what actually kind of helps
them a little bit so you're right if he
gets touched by you know the heavyweight
it's not as forgiving as a 205 yeah yeah
I think his toughest matchup to be
honest I you know in France you know I
love you I don't think it's France
Francis Lance that's gonna be a trouble
I think that Cyril got 100 agree how
athletic he is yeah because that's a
similar style
who's the guy that honestly a lot of
people and myself included I thought
John actually lost a decision on that
one which one um Reyes yes yes yeah I
actually have I didn't I thought it was
the first three rounds was Reyes and
then rounds you know four and five John
showed the championship rounds but I
didn't think the takedown in the third
was enough to win it over and Reyes has
a very mobile style moving backwards
attacking throwing and uh you know zero
God I think is all that with knockout
correct yeah
dicey yeah but I do think actually out
of the fights I think France is the
easiest fight for him not the easiest
obviously it's Francis and Ghana was a
champion if he touches him right but if
anybody touches you uh but if uh but all
he has to do is clinch with him once you
know what I mean like get him down yeah
once he grabs him takes them down like
it's once he grabs him the fight's over
yeah if I watch the clinch I'm like dude
it's done and he's that his grappling's
that strong yeah but but you know this
is where he's good that's why I
interrupted Frank this way uh John's an
outlier too is in the clinch people
don't realize how good he is in the clan
and that's at heavyweight a lot of it's
in the clinch gives me a problem yeah
super strong
kale Sanderson right I had a coach of
mine that at the time it was one of his
prodigies and trailer them a lot so uh
they when John first you know was
College actually was looking to recruit
him out of junior college and uh the uh
the college he was at tried to maybe
take him up to Penn but he goes ah
John's just he's seen it then what
everybody else in the world discovered
that John was going to be a you know a
bit of an issue off the mat to deal with
you know but uh we had him at the house
so you know my coach said hey so how
good is John he goes oh maybe the little
gold medalists
and that's coming from the most
successful wrestler both as a coach and
as an athlete he gave him the moniker
like yeah cosine that goes yeah that guy
if he wants to use the Olympic gold
medalist is right there yeah the
heavyweight and you know people won't
argue khabib whoever there's pound for
pound the greatest fall time is John
there's the you know whatever it'd be
like OPD cool whatever the guy's just
fighting around PDS I'm telling you man
yeah there's nobody better to ever enter
that ring without gun than Jon Jones he
wins the heavyweight title that
conversation's [ __ ] over for
everybody he will he's just it's
frustrating for me you know because I'm
such a yeah doing know why this keeps
getting pushed off
so I think it's so francis's contract
situation is he's he's he's under
contract because of the champ claws
champ claws is going to get superseded
by his Sunset Clause descent in like
December 15th so he's an unrestricted
free agent December 15th anytime I see
anything about about you know Jon Jones
we're targeting this and that with Stipe
I'm like okay they're playing leverage
against Francis trying to get him to
resign if they say oh we're doing France
anything having to do with Jon Jones
right now in my opinion is a tool being
used to try to resign Francis the second
they resign Francis they'll make that
fight because that's a fight that they
want they really don't want uh Stipe
Jones they'd be down to do it but it's
all pretty predicated off uh Francis so
I'm really close Francis agent Marquel
and I was talking to him and he was like
um you know we want the John fight we
want to make it happen but we're only
going to sign the contract if they allow
us to box yeah and I go well just sign
the contract and then uh fight Jon in
the box after and if he's if he beats
Jon think about the amount of attention
he's gonna get if he's fight fighting a
Deontay Wilder or fighting Anthony
Joshua uh you know Tyson Fury yeah he
goes but we don't want that it's too
much of a risk we want to resign box
yeah those big names
I mean the John's a high risky fight
because you know if I have to break down
francis's weakness is obviously
grappling but also being stuck in that
clinch and grinding with John even if
John doesn't take him down for two or
three minutes just locking onto him
moving and getting beat up with names
John throws a knee over the top just
that type of high Pace that's the
mistake miocic made in his fight with
him the second time is he didn't push
the pace at all and I know to take a
risk like well you're gonna get hit
anyways but get hit by a guy who's
throwing 30 punches around not the guy
who's only throwing five because those
five are gonna have a lot more Steam on
them you know what I mean like get him
to throw like get him busy you gotta you
have to wear Francis out it's gonna be
it's gonna be a risk no matter what I
told him to tell I said you know again I
love Francis he's being an underdog no
matter what path you go so if you box
first whether it's Anthony Joshua
Deontay Wilder Texas he's a massive
Underdog there's gonna be money there
but that's the losses and it's
detrimental I think to us if he gets
ko'd yeah maybe not because you know but
then beat up by John moving up I think
it's more judgment wait for sure yeah
the thing is I think one of the main
reasons why the UFC has been so
apprehensive about letting him do it is
because the conversation has been about
Tyson Fury I think Dana and anybody
that's brass of the UFC ghost they look
at that and they're like he's gonna go
in there he's gonna get [ __ ]
annihilated he's gonna get demolished I
think that you might be able to sell it
if you shift the conversation to Deontay
Wilderness that was a that's my thing
like he might be uh I don't know plus 2
000 against Tyson Fury he's not being
typhoon there's no chance no no and now
Anthony Joshua and Deontay Wilder now I
could see him in this weird world we
live in especially Dante Wilder him
Landing because Deontay Wilder you know
he doesn't have the best fundamentals he
just has the big right hand same as
Francis I could see that being more you
know that that's uh it's not a great
fight for none of them are great fight
for him he's definitely uh someone's
getting knocked out yes
yeah he's not gonna get out you know
slicked in that one he's just he's never
been to land on Tyson yeah I'm Tyson
would clench his head pull him down
around clinch wear him out yeah he's
gonna be the legs are going to get
locked up and as we you know staggering
around like there's just no way that
guy's you know no I think that is
awesome markel's my dude too and and
wherever this thing ends up with Francis
you know I I would throw in a mountain
of credit in markel's Direction in that
no like
Francis had to literally gamble
everything to get into the position that
he's in like they were trying to sign up
I mean he left millions of dollars on
the table in both his previous two
fights and he was like nope think about
the gamble against zero gun dude
with one leg torn him and then out
grappled seragan to win yeah himself
it's not dealt with a lot of
psychological stuff before that I mean
some of those phone calls I mean I don't
know how true they were or not but it
sounds like he was dealing with some
crazy attacks dude yeah okay like I mean
I mean like you know like a lot of
Fighters would have wilted under that
yeah sitting there going oh [ __ ] you
know I mean like you know what I mean
like if I don't pull this off I'm done
and it's crazy
the Town Square they're like all right
you see what happens you step out of
line there you go 150 150. you like your
new contract yep yeah 100 yeah but
markel's took out so much [ __ ] too man I
mean this threw him under the bus man I
and I've talked to Marco about this a
million times like I was always like
don't take it personal it's a strategy
because they're they're they're looking
at this unsolvable problem and they're
like we need to break this apart like
it's like we try to isolate for instance
yeah we would like markel's trying to
get him a hundred million dollar boxing
deal we don't want him to do it like
let's go poison the publicity you know
with Markel it's like the idea that
Markel is a bad manager you're like
he's the heavyweight champion he's gonna
be an unrestricted free agent like
clearly yeah that's a smart move you got
personal with those texts you received I
don't know if you saw those yeah yeah I
was like Jesus Christ yeah it's a good
play for keep yeah yeah that's what's
gonna happen man like it's part of the
game you know like you know you're
messing with the big machine there well
I mean it's not even just about Francis
I mean they're looking big to him I mean
if he goes you know it just sets yes
just like when one guy first guy breaks
10 million now it's all going to come
stormy now you know like every time you
break a number and one athlete
accomplishes something you know Francis
goes and accomplishes or maybe possibly
can you know be I mean hell if he sets
up to be a dual athlete going and boxing
and doing this well Connor said that you
know set that blueprint you know
everyone's like well he got to fight
Florida but now but Conor did it but I
think people also too sometimes Connor's
like well that's Connor yeah you know
you can almost have that conversation
yeah now Francis does it I think now the
UFC is going to have a lot more guys
asking for it like they don't want to
have those conversations and yet I get
that point with like if I'm Dana I'm I'm
playing hardball too 100
and the other thing is they've now all
of them the sunset Clause that's in
francis's contract
everybody has those now and they never
did before you know like Nick that's why
Nate Diaz has the you know was was you
know facing free agency either way is
like they had to fight him yeah yeah and
but the because before I think having
that class action lawsuit that's one of
the main things they had is they had
like in the old contracts they had I
mean you guys would know better than me
so much [ __ ] that you could just never
get you could never get free all the
extensions are very one-sided yeah yeah
the reason UFC so Dominos have the best
lawyers it's a nightmare when I retired
there's like hey cool man good good luck
with whatever you're trying to do if you
come out of retirement we own your rides
like we're just freezing your contract
okay like just because you're retiring
doesn't mean that you're out of there
I'll see that's what you signed yeah
that's what you signed way to go lawyers
yeah but like when they were building
the sport though they really did have to
have people locked in to be able to like
build the narratives that we're gonna
build interest in the sport you know and
they need a new Superstar I mean you
know the the guy and they're they're on
a track there because you look at the
next there's kind of it happens all the
time like there's the changing of the
guards I'm not 55 I think and then also
you know just with the superstars in
general because like comms up you know
it's kind of the next big thing which I
you know I don't know if he's gonna
translate to the American audience but I
don't think they're that concerned about
America they've kind of got the market
covered here like we're good here so
there's things all International so
hamzat plays that role
in China than here you know really and
that's why to tonight or today tonight
in Abu Dhabi but today here in Salt Lake
City we're watching it you know with
Suga he's the next American face they
want him to win so bad yeah I mean how
many viewers does he have I think
Instagram's like 2 million he has 2.5
million and he has it's like more than
like I think more than any other champ
in the UFC except for like three or
something like that yeah you think about
it he's yeah you know ranked what 11 or
something it's nuts no you do a video on
him and it gets way more views than you
know anyone else oh he's done me solids
like when I you know when I left
Showtime took a risk and I needed a big
guess for food truck Diaries He was the
first he was like oh man came out there
yeah it's not the best I love him man
he's such a good guy he's good people
there you can tell I can he's got such a
good shtick man like where uh you could
tell it's him and simultaneously he's
he's very intentionally doing this on
purpose oh Patrol guys like when when
the Peter John fight was announced he
goes uh he tweeted this out Brett Brett
akamoto put out this great article today
and it's been and uh he said he's at
lunch with uh Suga and it's when the
fight got announced and she was like yo
got announce watch this and he's like uh
Peter Young won't touch me and you know
and clearly he's not insane he's just
doing that to trolls yeah to get
engagement did you see the clip of yawn
and him passing each other yes no they
passed each other and and kind of looked
at each other and uh and yawned us
tomorrow I eat you Jesus Christ do you
hear what they they have to get a
translator for what uh Charles Oliver
was saying Wayans no what do you say uh
is the exact word was I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you
yeah yeah I'm into it man yes I'm into
it
and then also with it so you got you got
sugar Sean where a few wins that's a big
deal then you know again I'm all up on
his uh Penn State Nittany line nuts but
I think Beau Nichols the the Savior for
Americans we need some American power
it's Beau nickel even though he pulled
out of the fight he got injured I'm
disclosed oh really injured yeah so he's
out of the December you know how serious
it is I don't know but they pulled them
they're gonna reschedule them so I bet
they put them on that London card what
do you guys think about throwing them in
there with a like just like first time
ever they're just like let's see what
this guy's got total mystery and they
put him in there with the top guy like
they they actually did a hamster fight
like right now he's I'm oh I'm always
because you know my background and you
know I felt like I was pushed too soon
too fast and didn't have the experience
with Bo nickel you're dealing with a
different he's the only guy like yeah I
do that he's the only guy yeah I love
him I was like dude hell yeah I'm that
fight I'm like I'm not mad honestly I
mean this might be you know anybody
short of Izzy's name at middleweight on
the other side I have full comment me
too that
still the champion you know his mobility
and his you know I mean I'm not going to
say that I would be as confident as I
would be with everybody else just about
anybody else I'd go ahead and be all
right what do you want I'll I'll put a
thousand on it yeah what did you think
about him going from Mount and then
going inverted and finishing with the
trying to show the diversity that he's
learning you know what I mean because
those aren't things that he was you know
obviously doing in our wrestling match
he's a blue belt yeah I mean so I'm like
legitimately like applying and structure
sound angles and stuff like I'm like wow
so not only can this guy because that's
always been my criticism of some guys
with high level wrestlers I'm like
you're getting these great positions
finish the guy you know I mean like
choke him out like make your life easy
do you want to go home you're not
getting paid for these extra rounds but
a lot of them don't have that the the
mindset to finish it because they're not
to them like who's gonna take me down my
wrestling so good the most time
defend defend Jiu Jitsu like you know
most of the time you roll guys good
wrestlers D1 guy that come in the room
they don't want to learn how to finish
somebody they want to learn how not to
get finished not to get caught I'm like
okay so you just want to wrestle someone
for you know 15 to 25 minutes so the
stories coming out of ATT about Bo or in
the top caliber guys he's going against
when they tell me how he does against
these top guys I'm like holy [ __ ] yeah I
believe I mean look what he did to
people on a Collegiate level the
wrestling I mean he would hit moves it's
like man like the guy just manhandled
the number two guy in the country he
just like smashed and pinning people
just through tournaments I mean just you
know how long was he on you guys radar
before he was in a hot second hot so you
mean Rogan talking on for a hot second
though yeah just because he came on the
radar because he's always wanted to
fight mmas talked about even when he was
coming up through the wrestling program
and then his first fight was on Fight
Pass it's the most watched thing ever on
Fight Pass really the numbers he draws
in yeah damn yeah he's a champ too he's
all Iced Out on this stuff
real good yeah yeah
my my only caveat with Charles Oliveira
is you look at his how long you know
he's been in the UFC since he was 20.
you know he started off eight and eight
and he's won 11 a row and he started
that's what it was
almost almost getting cut
um the only thing about Charles and you
know it's too Frank it's like those
fights especially even recently the ones
that he's won you know he's walked
through murders row to become world
champion he takes punishment yeah it's
good you already got his eyes fixed
right oh did he like you know like uh
you remember when he was walking out
from one of those and some guy snatched
his glasses yeah and they were like dude
he's blind
he he has uh he got he got well probably
PRK because if you fight you're not
supposed to get Lasik like yeah I got
PRK for that same reason because like
they're you know you're the dislodges
the flap I got Lasik and just light
every time really every single
commission paper yeah oh you have to lie
to the commission about that I just
thought that the doctor will not
recommend it no no so you can get PRK
though yeah you're speaking about when
you know
about Charles as far as taking that
damage the residual abuse is going
through because the thing is like you
just never know what's going to hit I
remember actually thinking that right
now with uh I was watching the Ferguson
Diaz fight you know at first I was like
oh man Ferguson's a tough guy but I
think that gagey fight and all the
fights that Ferguson had Ferguson was
the same wages would take a lot of
beating I mean I sit there watch if I
remember watching Cerrone I thought
Donald Trump was piecing him up in the
first round of shots if you look at his
face no marks on him and then every time
he lands it's a visibly crushing Cerrone
yeah so the guy I think like took a lot
of abuse and then I watched the nadius
fight like the way he was spinning
around the way he's moving I'm like it
just looks off I'm like oh I think he's
I think he's I think cartilage where uh
yeah he can't follow time yeah
especially like certain style like Tony
Ferguson's style is not like uh an old
man style like Nate Diaz adjusted to his
age and how he slowed down yeah his
style you know very plotty and helped
Pace himself Tony virgin's style you
know he's so Dynamic and just like
Charles over there when it catches up
they turn you know yeah like I really
fall overnight yeah that's how I thought
I was sitting there I was watching the
fight I was like oh man you know what I
don't know if he ever recovered from the
gaichi fight yeah you know I think that
was you know I mean like that beating
was the one too many yeah it's like I
mean spinning around turning his back it
was just odd stuff the way this fight
I'm like look at the fight that is just
off what's going on here it's not as
fast not as fluid a lot of mistakes yeah
just you know just like I'm like man
like this but it happens to guys and you
don't know like I don't it could happen
to trouble that's what I'm saying that's
only it's just one time you don't know
until you don't know until you get in
there you're not gonna known training
you get in there you're like oh it
happened yeah and I said happened to
steepe I really think happened
this is what's worried about Stevie it
happened to steepe but he won the fight
against Francis but if you go back and
watch that fight and I was there he took
all the shots yeah Francis and after
that it's been a little you know a
little different for him he got starch
to this next fight against no not not as
bad because he's heavyweight so it's
different but not as bad as Tony first
yeah he's decline but definitely slow
like when I after that fight
I used to say on the channel I was like
just imagine a human being as a meat
suit like forget there's a person in and
just picture it like it's a big slab of
meat and then imagine Justin gaichi
putting the punishment on that thing
that he put on you know on Tony Ferguson
and then imagine like all of that's
gonna heal but it's not gonna heal back
perfect like it's you know you get like
weird scarring to cartilage like he's
not like that's not a beating that
you're gonna do but the one thing can't
heal is the brain yeah and that once the
brain takes enough punishment it's just
it's not firing all cylinders it's not
moving the same way yeah we don't know
when that's going to catch up to Charles
I don't think it's gonna be tonight
that's why I do pick him to win and I've
you know I've reasons this this fight's
fantastic this to me this probably is
your fight of the night who knows and
now if this isn't final night that means
we have a good night yeah you know what
I'm saying but like gamra and uh uh
Darius is a ridiculous fight I'm not
crazy they gave darius's fight I think
you deserves better meaning that gamrat
is a guy who's impossible to finish it's
a nightmare of a fight it's like what's
this guy have to do
yeah you know they thought it's gonna be
the alternative yeah so but you're
fighting gamrat not a great [ __ ]
fight great coaching has Mike Brown in
his corner you know I'm just not crazy
about oh I didn't know Gamera was ATT oh
yeah yeah Savage Savage now dudes you
know world champion Jutsu in a ghee
which I usually favor when guys do more
ghee if when they win the World
Championships and ghee and then they can
adapt it with no gee I usually favor the
guys in the ghee the fundamental stuff
like that just different
but if he thinks he's just gonna take
Darius down and like write him out
you're in for a good Awakening his
Jujitsu is legit do you know the one
thing about the Charles and Islam fight
that I'm thinking about right now is
like in in all those fights where Islam
got touched he got knocked down in most
of them if not all of them
but the thing that's different about the
Islam fight versus those other ones is
when Charles gets knocked down there's
nobody diving on that like there's no
one like diving in to try to finish it
he's on his back like this they're all
[ __ ] that no and so he gets to recover
because most days of UFC fight of all
time yeah I mean now he's not gonna snap
your [ __ ] shoulder out like this
Savage break your [ __ ] awesome
[ __ ] yeah who's playing for Keys yeah
who just broke breaking 300 Pounders no
I can't even [ __ ] salute anybody
anymore son of a [ __ ]
although I appreciate that I appreciate
that because he knocked me out the [ __ ]
break man break fully redeemed us man
actually I think that's one thing that
could be a weakness for Islam is that
because of Ensemble background you know
submissions even though like I I still
feel like he's more wrestling based 100
than he is that but yeah I think he has
enough familiarity there I think he
might have the confidence to dive in
there dive in on there you know because
I always tell people I've always thought
that when guys were training for me and
be like oh man this guy's flew these
black belts in there he's training I'm
like oh that's the worst thing you could
have done why so you're actually going
to feel comfortable trying to exchange
there like now if you pretend you're a
bar of soap and just you know every time
I try to grab you like oh [ __ ] I'm out
of here that's a pain in the ass for me
yeah yeah that sucks you're gonna go the
guy no I'm not gonna play frustrating
yeah the minute you're like oh I'm gonna
play with I'm like really all right yeah
all right we're gonna play my game all
right cool this is fun thank you guys
spider gotta fly in his web yeah yeah
but if you're gonna bolt and run like
you know and keep distance like all
right well that screws me up you know so
I think sometimes like sometimes being
comfortable in an area like there's that
middle like you know just enough to for
it to be dangerous for you yeah yep
we're uh where oh lover can get a finish
because I the way I picture the fight
going down Charles Oliver is going to
get taken down I bet my last [ __ ]
dollar unless there's a flying knee or
in the 30 seconds and you get starch
he's gonna get Charles Oliver down I
don't think you realize is down there
the amount of [ __ ] Fury is going to
throw elbows submission this submission
I think eventually Mark just like all
right [ __ ] let's go to the feet all
right so if I told you this fight was
gonna up being a sparring match on the
feet who you put that's funny Charles
who's telling me they're like yeah but
no one submits people off their back
anymore oh no what that's inaccurate I
see triangles all the time and guess
what when you lock up a guilty and you
jump guard is that not off your back you
know what I mean like yeah I I haven't
really seen people do too many mountain
Guillotines you've seen Charles Oliver
get your neck and that to me now he
grabs your neck he tries to rip yeah and
also with Mark Jeff too those
transitions there's nobody on his team
who has the submission transitions like
no you can't train for it so I just
think for 25 minutes you tell me I can
have one haircut yeah and Charles is so
[ __ ] good all he needs is just a you
give him an inch you get one mistake I
like I like the odds and you got and
like you know for one though so that's
fair but but you got the Hamza and burns
fight to go reference also because
that's a very very similar matchup you
know where you got like Hamza you know
is Islam and then you got Burns is
basically you know Charles yeah and as
soon as they as soon as they got into an
exchange where where Gilbert was on his
back he snatched one of hamzat's arms
and homicide pulled it out and then
never went down there ever again and
they ended up yeah Gilbert's a world
champion in gee too so he's a Savage
down there but even as good as Gilbert
is when it comes to MMA jiu zoo and
those transitions being dangerous that
we've never seen by Lake Charles this
guy yeah Charles the best right now yeah
ever yeah
Steve Hargett my professor is a world
champion also he thinks uh he thinks
Paul Craig has excellent like he's like
if he compliments someone's Jiu Jitsu it
means it's really [ __ ] Goods I
thought he almost hit my my submission
uh did you when he hit the arm bar he
actually had the shoulder lock there for
a second oh really yeah if you go back
and watch it from close guard he locked
it up and started pulling on the
shoulder lock I was like oh holy oh
someone's gonna get it and then he
flipped it over to a regular arm bar and
just shattered the guy's arms
Hill yeah yeah he's like oh my elbow no
Paul Craig is connected yeah vicious
Hill took that pretty [ __ ] well
though he's like oh I guess I guess and
he has confidence he's just jumping
guard and stuff you know I mean pulls
half guard you know which you know
if you're good at grappling and good at
Jiu Jitsu I don't see a problem pulling
half guards
that's how I train the guys now like I
do it even more it's like hey half car
is a head inside single you know what I
mean like you know if your hands are
connected you know you can do a lot of
damage and be very dangerous and
sweeping and moving off your back you
know I thought even in uh the Shane
Carwin fight which I was Shane's main
trading partner for that fight getting
ready for you I was like if I'm Frank
because we're trying to think as if I'm
Frank dude and you know because you're
so big and powerful everyone I'm pulling
half guard I don't remember that fight
you and how do I not remember that's for
the interim heavyweight title shame
became uh Champion it was in uh our
strategy actually was just like just
don't do nothing crazy and let the fight
go deeper waters we felt it like this
yeah yeah and that he had bad cardio but
I just knew he wouldn't be as powerful
he's still 285 [ __ ] pound guys all
right his power how it can't be I mean
nobody's as powerful the first one the
second one yeah and then as the power
decreases it'll be less dangerous yeah
so and and like dude Carwin how big are
his [ __ ] hands enormous I think
they're the largest hands ever that's it
I heard hands everywhere bigger than
Francis see Darius is very dangerous
down here man in these transitions like
high level blackmail I'm telling you man
oh he's got a leg yep let's use it as a
sweet oh it's awesome yeah that's sick
yeah he's super high level oh he's still
holding on to it if he can get his butt
back but he could have had his back
there no
get his feet I thought this would be a
good grappling match yeah yeah man um
like you two guys like oh man this would
be a great grappling match and then they
both just end up seeing B level boxing
versus Maya yeah you're like what are
you guys doing how dare yeah yeah that
was that was a rough one amateur boxing
match just how dare you in the world
class on the ground this one Darius the
thing about Dairy which is obviously
super uh versed on the ground but he has
that where if he gets clipped he just
throws caution out the window and that's
why he's so exciting
too I mean good late kicks could sound
there he goes we're already seeing some
display of his low kicks his thing too
you know with the UFC he obviously
deserves the title shot but at 55 it's
[ __ ] stacked but
you know he has that like Leave it to
Beaver like Wally thing was like I just
want to thank Jesus Christ Lord and
Savior like I like everybody and UFC's
like no
you want to kill Lucifer and we'll give
you a [ __ ] that's how he wants to
kill somebody go hang out with takashi69
and party and he's like no man they're
like haven't you seen the Dustin Johnson
the DJ movie where we shipped him off to
one FC because he was here's what's
crazy even if he beats camera I don't
think they'll give him a title no I
don't think so either which is nuts well
because if Chandler beats Poirier
they'll give it to him for sure yes
so he keeps using the words of the
hurricane sweep that uh that uh cyborg
uses he's used it twice now to go and
cut underneath throw him over the top
and then he grabs both legs Darius does
and he uses it and that's what I always
tell people you can go for leg attacks
but you have to make sure you end up on
top use it as a sweep at the very least
because if you're on bottom they can
just smash it yeah you can smash the
things this is the things sometimes I
see with the nogi no points I kind of
don't agree with it and I used to think
I'd be a fan of it but I'm like look
points are rewarded in position and
position matters when we fight each
other so if you don't reward positions
like then guys don't go for it so I see
some of these guys do the no GE turn or
no points you know they they slide on
their back and just kind of well you
know they'll do inverted guards stand
there I'm like all right those are you
know give up Mount I'm like ah you
wouldn't do this if I was punching you
know what I mean yeah what do you think
what do you think about Eddie Bravo's
new thing with the open-handed uh
strikes I think it's a step in the right
side yeah I just now I think it should
be a building tool for guys that are
great Grapplers or you know you grapple
and you're like okay I'd like to do MMA
here's a transitionary uh step for me
where I'm not getting with a guy with
his hand taped closed fist knocking
around yeah we're getting an elbow
dropped in my head so now I can train my
positions and movements in a way that
will punish me for you know hey you know
but now it's a slap and not a full-close
fish yeah it's a step closer to those
guys but I don't know but I don't agree
with someone like me doing the
tournament it's like okay hold on a
second like you've already done MMA
that's like stepping backwards to do an
amateur like yeah let this be for the
guys moving towards missionary as a
stepping around I don't want to see a
MMA fighter doing it I want to see
Rattlers it would be
[Music]
the way I found out about that sport was
there was a a real or a short video
where this dude got [ __ ] murked yeah
like with a palm he was a guy went for a
like a probably a knee bar or something
that is any or a foot lock and he had
his this dude just took his palm and
Boston yeah that's filthy he was yeah I
mean people think of slap with this part
of the hand over my back if you slap
Palmer yeah that's like when you see a
slap contest but I've watched it another
you know hey would you ever do that like
never in a million years yeah we would
start at like eight figures before you
get me to even think about doing that
because the brain damage on that I'm
like yeah stand there and take a shot
I'm like yeah you know I did martial
arts because I have an aversion to pain
yes yeah I mean like I wanted the
easiest way through this you know not
isn't it you know Dana and the fertittas
or they bought a slap fight I know you
hear they signed uh Will Smith a six
fight contract
I'll be here
seven Late Show 9 30. that's a great
show last night thanks brother
can you imagine they did sign Will Smith
how much money oh my god dude it might
be worth it they paid him
can you imagine if they had announced
that the the slap Fight League and Will
Smith was their main event dude they
should definitely make him an offer they
don't have the money even though they're
that rich I mean Will Smith is like yeah
he's like Hollywood royalty he's in like
Men In Black seven yeah you know he's
making 50 million a movie they're not
gonna pay him that I remember talking to
people from his agency like after that
whole thing happened and I'm like dude
so what's your strategy that all he's
going dark like he's and he's like he
just went dark and he didn't he did that
weird like apology yeah it looked like
he was held in Austin those are weird
like I mean like wow but the whole
situation like I try not to pay
attention to this crap but like I have a
wife that like sits next to me in bed
and watches this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my God
so sometimes I got information yeah and
I really don't mean to get it no I don't
want to know this I do a lot of taking
up space [ __ ] what does she think she
liked it or didn't like it oh no she was
embarrassed by it too I'd watch it she
goes now that's ridiculous stack like
that like but then I told her I said
yeah but like I think the problem is
that he didn't handle the first
situation that's entanglement or
whatever yes yes wait a minute that dude
should have got [ __ ] up like why
didn't you sleep the wrong guy that's
who he slapping
Illustrated his masculinity he's been
called in like basically come on look as
men if you're a woman's messing around
on you and everybody knows and you don't
do nothing like no man's not respect for
you come on mess around dude they went
on family vacation Hawaii and then she
for two days flew him out so will was
aware of it wow man yeah ultimately so
he's feeling about his emasculators you
could possibly she brought him on
national TV to talk about it too yeah
and then sits there and like oh she does
the red table talk once a week out of
their [ __ ] free you know in their
kitchen he's making eggs in the morning
she's like yes I was sucking August's
dick yeah oh okay are you serious oh wow
in front of their kids too dude yeah
really like your kids
all the all the Fury from that situation
on its own and then imagine like
thinking about how you look to your own
kids with your wife and their mom
[ __ ] some 21 year old who is friends
with one of the kids all she's done is
embarrassed them yeah her show is just
just he's on there crying and [ __ ] all
the time yo I didn't realize the Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air wow yeah the guy the
guy yeah
wow I didn't even know that much
that's why I was like I can't believe it
took this long yeah yeah that dude like
I'm surprised he didn't shoot somebody
now but you know the dude this is gonna
be a lot worse yeah they should have
ends with their son that's how she met
him yeah I didn't know that part okay
well I didn't know it was that blatant
yeah in your face yeah wow no respect
wow I love the part on the red table
talk where they're like where she's like
I mean and no one's gonna tell me what I
can do with my body he's all exactly
like No One's Gonna tell you that I'm
like are you [ __ ] serious you give my
wife's all hey uh I'm gonna go take a
picture of my vagina and then I'm gonna
go [ __ ] the neighbor I'd be like yeah no
you're not like that's not me like
that's just common I'd be like kids I'll
see you in 20 years yeah exactly Dad
yeah Mom's lost your mind I'm gonna
straighten it up real quick
Dad's doing a hard we're gonna be a
realignment here on the hierarchy of how
this works re-education
dad's going to stay on an all-inclusive
resort called Pelican Bay for about 10
years so you know you're worried about
my weight I'm gonna be on a street night
now
yeah the truth is nuts like it just that
is yeah wow I'm just I'm shocked aren't
you and then when Tupac you know his
it's like the anniversary of his death
she always posts how much he misses yeah
stuff I can you imagine I was like what
are you doing and then it's not like
it's just behind closed doors like it's
it's on this huge platform the red table
you know what kind of makes sense to me
is like I remember I've always heard
these rumors before that like
he doesn't swing that way like like it's
almost like she's oh he's got a beard
like where a woman pretends that you
know like yeah yeah that's his beard you
know what I mean like yeah or she's how
that works back and forth yeah in
Hollywood it's pretty well he's down for
both ways as well yeah yeah yeah and
that would make more sense because I
think to a guy like that that wouldn't
be as
troubling yeah man like and God bless
him being open-minded but uh yeah I
heard she orders for him and [ __ ] when
they go to dinner she'll be like we'll
have the chicken tender get the [ __ ]
yeah no I made that up but
at this point though I really that'd be
the least of his problem yeah right he's
like I will have the chicken dinner
I was sitting there talking jeez that
red table talk was hard she's like she's
hot it's just I just hadn't felt good in
so long I just wanted to feel good I'm
like Will Smith's just sitting extra
like right right
well this fight has been a uh a war
dude I had a buddy who found out that
his wife was cheating on him when
he had one of my friends over and she
was at her mom's and one of the iPads
had reset like so like like you know did
an update so a reset and her text
messages started coming through this
iPad and he's sitting here looking at
her having a conversation with the dude
who she had been having an affair with
she had just they had just had another
kid and in this text message thread
she's like uh he's like I can't wait
until I can bottom you out again and
she's like I can't wait for that either
and he showed it to my other buddy he's
like he's always he's like is this what
I think it is my buddy's like dude it's
not good man
not good the next we were also go
camping the next day and he definitely
dropped out he dropped out and I had to
drive the other guy up with us and he
was like dude
I can't even cheers that'd be a very
awkward room to be into your boy's
seeing that yeah oh bro he came up from
La was staying with him in Sacramento
for the night before we were driving up
to Shasta he's just there for one night
and that [ __ ] oh I try to make my buddy
feel good I'm like dude she's just
trolling you dude she knows you're
watching this she knows you're reading
this she's just [ __ ] that's a good
guy yeah that's true I wouldn't have
thought that quickly yeah I text her
she's like see your conversation you
[ __ ] [ __ ] what are you doing
that's awful that but you know that's
like all that 23andMe stuff now like uh
you know all these grandparents are
finding out that like you know if you've
seen that now let me see like no I know
I know it catches that are like siblings
and like not realizing they're not
really siblings and stuff because Mom
was cheating on her grandma was cheating
on Grandma yeah like you know grandpa
might have had some illegitimate kids
over there but all of a sudden Grandma
was getting yeah yeah and then oh man
heck is back then I mean look I mean as
long as you like you hooked up with a
dude that looked kind of like your
husband they never thought they're gonna
get caught and all of a sudden like you
know you have sisters and aunts and then
you know going and doing it and then
finding out they're like oh wow we're
not related we're only happy at this
point do you even say anything Grandma's
99 I know it's like statutory there's
some yeah that's just like it becomes a
discussion now you know Chris was gonna
be a little awkward you know yeah I'd
probably just leave it that's crazy yeah
right yeah actually I think I saw a stat
where they said like what was it like I
think it was like uh the England or the
whole British uh Isles it was uh three
percent of the the men are raising
children that are not their own
unknowingly oh wow wow that's a big
number yeah it's a huge that's 100
people get on girls and guys the whole
you know who cheats and stuff it's like
well yeah both do right yeah it's an
ugly thing but like you know but when
women do it like the consequences can
you know well now they keep their mouth
shut they don't want to say anything and
so now guys raising a kid that's not his
Jesus Christ
damned I mean we can get into you know
cutting hair is what's worse you know
but I don't know I think that's pretty
bad yeah either way you cut that thing
it's not good I would rather secretly
find out that the kid's not mine than
publicly be at the red top table and
have my life oh no I'd rather
because I've read some stories about
that happen so then like so like how
articles are you reading like could you
imagine looking over and find out your
kids not your kid like oh when you do do
you tell the kid now be like okay like
I'm not your dad like you know like
years from now we're like What do you
keep because like like you know like you
know like you know like my son and my
daughter you know my sons I love them
right yeah yeah to find out like I think
I would just take it to my grave I'd be
like all right no yeah it's the same
thing like if you adopt a kid right and
if you adopt a like a bit I'm talking a
baby looks like you I don't get the
upside of telling the kid he's adopted
like six days I agree what if he's like
crushing it doing his thing getting good
grades yeah what's my K life is going
good yeah the only argument that I could
possibly see for telling is like okay
certain diseases genetically now you
know I mean you might need to know oh
you know you're prone to or something
like oh you know I carry this whatever
and breast cancer yeah high percentage
or whatever but that's it other than
that you're waiting you're weighing that
against like probation yeah I'm just
like yeah the kids can be changed
forever yeah I think there's no upside I
think you know you got the next Steve
Jobs in your hand he hates you he
becomes an [ __ ] makes the Iphone
right I've seen it happen a thousand
times
no my wife and I talk about that all the
time we're like when like if someone
like husband and wife they do like trips
separate you know someone falls on a
dick in Vegas or or vice versa it's like
dude when they come back I'm like they
should don't [ __ ] say anything about
it it's like like if you don't go on
Facebook oh I feel guilty I feel really
guilty so I told her it's like I think
that's selfish the guilt is you're gonna
own it yeah
you're gonna unload that and [ __ ] I
agree with you whether your spouse's
life well I gotta tell you so I feel
better I'm like yeah but the other
person doesn't feel better yeah it's
like how about just don't do it again
that other person just don't do it like
just don't do it again to me like
everything has to serve a purpose if it
doesn't serve a purpose it's not
tactical exactly yeah exactly if I
adopted a black baby I'd like my ass off
like do you just tan
don't get a Twist who's tan man you're
gonna get a basketball too yeah man that
was really good I mean like that one
time makes you laugh because like you
know this couple obviously adopted a
black baby you know if they're a white
couple they're holding the baby the dogs
kind of like they just caught the dog
the dog's dog's like I got questions
Kid Rocks I like I think I saw in a
documentary Kid Rock's first kid was
with uh it was in there and like
everyone knew they're all dude that's
not a that's not a white baby my friend
Chris rocks no Kid Rock oh Kid Rock Kid
Rock well I always said about Michael
Jackson's kids like Michael Jackson's
kids came out white and I'm like looking
at him like wait a minute he used to be
super black yeah the whole Jackson
family is like black right like I'm like
looking at him like and I know he don't
look black anymore but that's all
artificial yeah
genetically he's a black guy so like
those kids don't look half at all to me
I never thought that I was like wait a
minute how is his kids that well the
jeans or this alone
have you ever seen someone like look
that white I don't know what's going on
there and then you're like can I imagine
Michael Jackson [ __ ] a girl down he's
like not really so remember when you
married
no no that wasn't good damn it
remember when he uh married uh Elvis
Presley's daughter that's who he had the
kids with right no no no no he had
another one but we had a surrogate
remember he did like yeah
it was the baby over the balcony yeah
it's frowned upon yeah
that was like a blanket or something
that might have been his baby
it was his kid but I think we had him it
was like the dentist's like a secretary
or something yeah but if I thought for
some reason too yeah
I stew Jujitsu his his son I forget his
name but he was young and he would do
the kid classes I'd coach someone MJ
senses MJ son was in there yeah did he
did he have any potential you know he
tried hard
it's hard to tell he's one of those
fights we were talking about uh
women cheating and adopted babies yeah
Will Smith
yeah that is tough I'm still hurting
right now for him poor [ __ ] guy man
Frank just found that out yeah I'm gonna
need a moment guys a lot more tequila to
get to that one
what are you are you guys going to the
comedy show tonight yeah because what
time oh about seven are you at the Early
Show
seven o'clock either I mean seven or
nine three whatever you guys want oh
come get something Salt Lake City
that way I'm gonna go back to the room
take a nap hang out and then we'll go to
the 931 yeah I did the night I did the
late one last night late one's usually
better right uh they're both good yeah
Saturday if they're both I guess we
should say that Friday Friday late
usually can get a little dicey because
they're at work all day and they start
drinking earlier but last night was
great yeah yeah you don't miss Salt Lake
this was one of the best clubs in the
nation dude shout out to Keith and Wise
Guys for allowing us to do it here too
it was awesome dude people always get
that like that dress like every girl I
saw was dulled to the nines I'm like is
that what people do when they go to
comedy shows yeah usually yeah
especially my crowd usually because you
know I like fashion and stuff so you'll
see a lot of dope sneakers too yeah yeah
even like Fort Wayne Indiana there's
some fire sneakers [ __ ] fire sneakers
like these I'm not those J's my man I
saw Camaro had them and I was like I
like those shoes and I bought them shout
out to Kamara on the on [ __ ]
Instagram with these ones yeah I love
Kamara man he's got a great style dude
yeah he's a beast now I can't wear half
the stuff because he just doesn't wear a
shirt sometimes I I wouldn't wear a
shirt you could wear that shirt that'd
be tough dude get on stage oof I don't
know I don't know I'll tell you what I
can do is take some happy hippo Kratom
listen if you like happy hippo Kratom
it's the only crate of my trust there's
a million Brands out there but it's the
Wild West it's like CBD back in the day
about five years ago you know who to
trust you can trust happy hippocratum
and you can use the promo code sick boy
you get 20 off for a live fam and you
can share that code with your aunt your
uncle your adopted kid that's not yours
whatever you want to do your mistress
your side piece give them the Code thick
boy.com 20 for life all you gotta do is
go to happyhippo.com promo code thick
boy it's the best Kratom on the freaking
planet I use the pink lemonade shot
before I hit the stage they got gummies
they got powders they got pills whatever
form it's the best kratom on the planet
that's Happy Hippo
happyhippo.com promo code thick boy to
himself for life do you find out your
kid's not yours you better get on that
Kratom yeah
yeah that'll fix you right up it's gonna
get your mind right damn Dare You Schwan
hell yeah that's nice dude that's not a
that's not a fight that's going to get
him a title shot though
Harrison can we talk about the fights
you guys got coming up have you
announced it yet
yeah you guys you guys get some uh Frank
you want to talk about this man well no
not yet as far as we were announcing
because we're still working that out but
we have our freedom fight nights coming
up our third show is coming up on
November 4th for people who are
interested in checking that out November
4th November 4th you're in Phoenix San
Antonio yep yep where is it Phoenix Mesa
area yeah uh what's the what's the name
the Bell
Arizona Federal
what is it what like uh who's fighting
that whole card will put up on the thing
uh um I'm bad at that as far as other
names right now go ahead and get on
there dude get on there pitch this card
for us dude I would love to tease the
big boy but we don't want to do it yet
yeah oh I have all the warming questions
after this you know the fight night so
we're starting out is basically a you
know look we started as kind of a
fundraiser really and when Harrison came
up to me and we were talking about doing
the fights I was like oh well we can
make it more like a I always like the
college wrestling duels you know what I
mean we're like how you go out there and
you win is points for your team so we
have this team scoring so we've started
really implementing that aspect into the
freedom fight night it's like all right
you have two coaches going against each
other it'd be Ryan Bader and Benson
Henderson and they get to pick you know
the fighters who pull out they have the
team and then at that point you know
they get to pick their their point
scores so you know you have you know
seven guys you know they're fighting for
you that night maybe you know four of
them are a video where the number would
come up with because it was our final
for the tournament coming up you pick
five guys or your Runners you know and
so okay these five guys can score for me
if they win by knockout or submission
you know six points if they win by you
know unanimous decision but every judge
gives you every round that's five points
working itself down if you're a
unanimous decision where all judges
thought you win but maybe not every
round is four point points and then you
know if all of a sudden you know the
split decision win is or uh three points
then a draw is only one or unanimous
draws two
um right so so that way at the end
um
when you go out of the fighting there's
a winning team that gets a bonus so
going out there and just wrestling
Financial bonus for the financial gain
so there's an incentive so if you go
back and your teammate goes hey buddy
you know you just took the guy down and
held him down or you knew you were
winning you just ran for the last round
you could have knocked him out yeah you
know what I mean like there's a bonus
here so and it kind of builds up the
camaraderie which I really like that to
have in our sporting World sometimes I
think fighting gets away from it and so
many guys come from a grappling
background where there is that
camaraderie well I know boxing doesn't
necessarily have that I mean he's got
some teammates but I've walked in and
trained a lot of boxing now I walk in
the gym it's you know even if you have
teammates it's kind of a lone wolf
yeah everybody has their own coaches
watching them and they go Spar and
whatnot but whereas uh the uh in
wrestling you know it's a team you know
Jiu Jitsu we're a team you know we work
together and I'd like to bring that more
into the MMA world that's awesome just
like you guys are talking about when we
first got on like uh you know you're
like first one out for your team and
yeah like you know yeah kind of like the
locker mentality yeah make it more now
okay now we'll incentivize if a couple
guys are maybe on the you know the the
the uh the line about it you know I mean
you know whether they want to push hard
or not you know and then I'll study the
crowd it kind of encounters you more
interest so if even if you're just
watching one particular fighter you went
there to see your buddy fight or you
have something you like watching other
fights now matter to you because it's
like okay well now scoring and I want to
see which team actually pulls it off and
what's going on holy [ __ ] is this fight
on right now it's still coming up next
this with a card gets tasty I mean not
that Dairy ocean camera it's not but
this is where it gets Superstar I love
guys where like they're they're like
just their little promo right there I'm
like dude I would be gassed it's so
awkward and you're like in the middle of
your thing like can we get you for 30
seconds of Shadow Boxing camera like God
damn it
it's like when you do reality you've
done some reality views and they're like
and they're like so say they're like
that was perfect now say it this way
you're all oh yeah
can you say that but now in 10 seconds
or not three minutes yeah I'm a
long-winded bastard yeah
what's the oh is he uh his dominance
yeah against Peter who you got in that
fight Jesse in uh Pierre versus uh uh
Izzy I think Izzy
I don't like everybody's counting them
out drives me nuts and then also if PR
wins loves you do the rematch but then
after that you tell me Bo nickel when
it's beat the brakes off that Pierre kid
yeah who can't wrestle can't grapple
yeah
such a knockout artist such a heavy hand
like it's crazy how hard the guy hits
yeah I mean and then he starts uh
Strickland now yeah we're just like I
mean wow that left hook is a [ __ ]
nuclear it is man you know it is yeah
and that's Strickland on food truck two
weeks ago I heard that interview was
awesome I haven't seen it yeah people
were commenting yeah it was great he was
great but he was talking about every
time up here and I go uh what was the
game plan there man you just you want to
go toe-to-toe and he's like no the plan
was to like feel them out and then start
to Grapple he's like but try to feel him
out like next thing I know I get knocked
down that wasn't the plan it was just
like and it was to actually he's like
jabbed the body jabbed the body jabbed
the body and then not a jab to the body
you're unconscious yeah I mean Pier is a
big dude that shot he hit him was on his
way down though this the straight after
he clipped him with the hook was Surge
this one Boop yeah dude but I think
people are mistaken too because
everyone's high and mighty on Pierre's
size you'll realize how big he is he is
I mean Izzy's not that big he's a little
more slender but Izzy's taller than me
yeah like because at the time when he
came on my show he was talking about it
was all about the Jon Jones fight yeah
and I was like he's a little undersized
and then he got shot from the van I was
like and I'll go holy [ __ ] dude but he
was I'm telling you dude I hear you keep
saying that two spawns and I'm tired not
that so I'm like you are not small man
yeah he's big anybody who's never seen
him you're tallest yeah and Izzy's
probably an inch taller than me yes me
neither yeah he's huge yo super [ __ ]
tall is Kevin Holland yeah for 170 tall
you you oh you not have them on never I
think he's six four I walked by it at uh
hotel at 274 and I was like Jesus that
guy weighs I weigh a buck 90. that guy
fights 20 pounds less than he's [ __ ]
enormous he's playing Wonderboy now
remember he's tired now they're fighting
Wonder Boy now Kevin Holland fan too
Tommy gets a lot of press stuff like
that you know he's kind of well I think
guys think about it too especially after
a while you don't have a transition and
all of a sudden a few injuries healed
that maybe you didn't think we're gonna
heal you feel you started helping other
guys out in the gym you know I mean I I
can see where this is going I've been
there after this Brown fight I was like
forget this this is terrible I [ __ ]
quit and I do an interview right after
I'm like I'm done and then weeks go by
I'm like you know what I'm gonna cut to
205. I started cutting I was like this
is awful I'm retiring yeah but also like
I think I think in that situation I
think his I think his money hit his bank
account like because you know he got
paid for that to take that um
retired he's just talking yeah he's like
under 30 made money I'm gonna get out
you know I already made 800. it was the
rumor good for him man yeah
that's still not like walk off home run
no it's not you know it's not actual
retirement no no no you're a huge NFL
MBA money where you're set for life pay
your pay your agent pay your taxes
you're you're keeping 350 of that
this this this fight is the biggest kind
of mystery to me like we're gonna find
out and you know sugar because I'm tired
I'm Elite and he's like that's why I
want this fight to prove to you guys I'm
a lead everyone just thinks I'm you know
this whatever twitch star and Instagram
star like this fight proves on my lead I
belong here so there's a lot more
pressure on sugar than his Peter that's
true it's not pressure Peter Young could
lose kick it starts in three seconds
it's still Peter John yeah sugar has a
lot more to prove than Peter John I just
don't see any chinks in Peter John's
armor like when I look at him like just
trying to size him up mentally like he
just looks 100 confident I think sugars
where he was uh ABC or ACB Champion
there coming two overseas oh yeah so I
got the you know call fights oh you're
the come to yeah that's right man
Austin Franklin we did the show together
I can't believe the UFC doesn't use them
as an analyst like when you did WC all
this stuff and the the when you're over
the restaurant I mean it's insane no I'm
with Harrison yeah that's true yeah you
got that other God I wish we could talk
about the [ __ ] fights you ever got
going on over there but we'll wait if
you announce anywhere else I'm gonna
move on bro I'm not gonna I'm not
converting Mormon Harrison did you do
anything for one yesterday yeah post and
I broke it down on the show nice yeah
win last night on one championship
the advantage for uh sugar is is reach
his long arms and sometimes if you watch
the way uh
um Peter Young blocks he frames it
doesn't move I think sometimes those
frames can create still holes if you can
get around them but that being said if
he starts reaching around those I think
his body's gonna be open for kicks yeah
so I think there's gonna be kind of like
more boxing from uh Shane trying to get
him you know remember too the sugar
Shawn if you know if you if you're gonna
look for a um a kind of [ __ ] in the
armor and you know I'm not you know
light kicks you know the Cheeto leg
kicks [ __ ] them up uh Pedro Munoz was
going for leg kicks Peter Young can
[ __ ] like yeah and so I think because
you don't have reasons I think Peter
Young's kicking's gonna be the factory
if he can't shut down and grappling yeah
it's phenomenal Grappler I really think
besides giving up the bag yeah grappled
uh you know I agree 100 yeah I mean just
that Al Jermaine is the I mean that guy
takes you back and he sinks in that body
triangle yeah he's on you you know yeah
like until the round ends he's not
coming off damn look at DraftKings says
one better put 8 500 bucks on sugar to
win to win 34 000.
and the juicy guy one submission go
decision
dude look at look at the pink here in
the crowd now that this is actually
happening
much less confident in Sean's like I got
a few prospects I mean I think it's I
mean I like Sean I like him a lot I
think that I mean I know he's been
already for several years in the UFC how
do you think goes down uh I think he's
gonna get this [ __ ] kicked out like not
then I don't mean like kicked as far as
you know getting I mean actually like
kicked yeah body kicks late kicks I
think he's gonna throw I just think that
versed uh peterion is and everything my
brain's like straight boxing switches
dances yeah you know but my heart's like
sugar exactly I want Sean I want Sean is
better for the sport to win sorry oh
Dana right now is like dear God I don't
ask for much I know you've already given
me 400 million all right dude be cool
but he's on a cold streak with like the
fights like this where you know he
really wants someone both the last two
Conor fights like uh I don't know
there's a bunch that like where I was
like they were doing this like the Colby
versus Camaro they were trying to set up
Camaro I'm sorry uh Colby versus versus
mosfit all for a title they tried that
three times and they could never get it
done because Camaro kept beating
everybody yeah this is such a you know
so there's so many questions going this
fight it's like because the one thing we
don't know about sugar oh and here's the
other thing in the main event too like
all that we know about Islam we've seen
him fight he hasn't like blown my hair
back but everything we know about Islam
has been from the his coaches from
khabib from DC from Josh Thompson he's
the best of all time it's like maybe
yeah I haven't seen it I haven't seen it
look you guys now here's the thing they
might be right yeah but as far as right
now at [ __ ] 12 20 or I'm sorry yeah
12 20 Pacific time and 120 mountain time
he's not we're gonna you guys are
telling me this yeah but from what I see
he's not yeah I could be completely
wrong and [ __ ] he's gonna go in there
mop the floor with Charles Oliveira
according to Josh Thompson he's like
you're going to be a fight man he said
I'm telling you I've seen [ __ ] that's
what they all said remember like before
Kane that's what I'm saying they said
all the same stuff and then they were
right same crew too I'm surprised you
never [ __ ] no we were supposed to uh
God that would have been
and then that's when they uh they
randomly drug tested all of us that were
on the card it was so me and cam were
supposed to be fighting uh Alistair was
going to be fighting uh JDS Bigfoot and
Roy Nelson oh and then when we all got
off stage we're in Vegas we're like all
right come over here to drug testing and
then how many guys pop dirty just one oh
and also ran away yeah they brought him
back that's the one with outsurd like
literally ran off it's like slight job
yeah okay I'm good and I'm like so then
I'm like hey uh so what's going on like
just gotta we gotta get him back here
I'm like all right well dude now you're
screwing up in my day I want to get the
hell out of here I know man so then they
brought Alistair back and then he failed
the drug test that's when they said he
gave him an injection for his ribs or
something yeah so then they they
switched up the fights was that that was
back when trt was allowed and there's
trt exemptions right and he popped like
five times the or whatever it was like
it was so high they're all this is not
trt dude yeah yeah you couldn't reverse
well I guess they had done that a couple
times but for the most part you had to
tell them you were gonna go do trt and
get it okay get to eat an exemption from
the
all right cool yeah he's the Wild West
for Peter John through this fight's
interesting because he in general you
know he does five he's a five round
fighter he's been fighting five rounds
for a hot second 100 he'll give rounds
away if you notice he's a slow starter
but not he he's downloading your
information and then he goes to work
yeah it's three rounds and this favors
you know sugar because Peter's used to
five rounds so Peter can't when it's
three rounds you can't give a round away
so by taking those chances and coming in
aggressive oh there's a guy that looks
like a guy from South Park those but
um so when he comes uh forward you know
it does open you up with sugar with his
knees elbows so yeah this is the most
intriguing fight to me man for sure so
these next three fights make my dick
Sean's gotta stick that front kick the
ball of his foot right in his solar plex
can I do that for 15 minutes against
Peter John remember Peter John's been
able to you know he's usually the
smaller guy he's used to it does this
look like a guy who he's gonna lose
he looks so [ __ ] confident he looks
like uh bro when's the last time
Predator when's the last time he saw a
Russian do a [ __ ] hat like cartwheel
like that
Sean is wonderful holy [ __ ]
explosion wow is that a rushing
cartwheel yeah dude
got dish so and Sean's usually pretty
easy-goosey but he's he looks nervous to
me like he should be I mean I would be
you should be it's Peter John man yeah
guys just he's just a different animal a
good combination of physical attributes
you know a great Chan great you know
strong fast powerful and then just he
does everything well yeah and everything
and then like you're right like and then
the brain of a masterful martial artist
and you know which typically those
sometimes don't all come together
sometimes you know why are you so smart
well because I'm not physically able to
do this I had to figure it out it's like
well no this guy's I mean you saw the
cart really did athletically he's just
you know yeah it's just on a different
level mentally just so smart and
remember he's Russian he's Siberian he's
Russian he's from Siberia he was nothing
more than to destroy yeah he was
unloading like those enormous ships in
Siberia when he was like from like age
11 on yeah he's the hardest thing on
earth I bet if you ask Peter John what
twitch is he would throw up that's yeah
what's your Twitch handle he's like yeah
you could you talk about two completely
different personalities and Fighters
sugar Sean I think they would get along
if they train together like if they were
on the same team they would get along I
don't know
I think Jan is wow Leon's different than
some of these other Russians I feel like
like he's like
he's got a lot of Personality look at
them he looks like a [ __ ] on the side
of the road you guys see that in the
press conference that's what Peter Young
said yeah though like uh about sugar
about sugar yeah man he's like a horse
he said in Russian he just like he said
it's so so confident in schneid and the
Russian translator is like he says look
at him he looks like a [ __ ] on the side
of the road
yeah you ain't dressing like that in
Russia my man yeah it's frowned and they
were like Sean they're like Sean do you
have a response he's on now that's
pretty good
Herzog yeah good ref too doesn't make a
lot of mistakes
oh my God I can't [ __ ] believe his
fight's on no
[Music]
Steve Harvey texting back there missing
the fights oh there you go now he looks
a little better
he usually starts like that comes out
the Jon Jones style here we go baby
there's just a lot riding on Suga to get
this done huh him and his coach
validation oh those kicks all right and
you know I'd love to I'd love to hear
the disagreement I wouldn't have gone
back to Orthodox I think he needs to
switch back to Southpaw like he said
though Jan's not taking this round off
you can already tell yeah he's pushing
the pace he knows the deal yeah if you
go watch johann's last [ __ ] four
fights or five rounds five fights
probably those first rounds he's so slow
but he's just downloading the data like
Floyd Mayweather he's getting your
timing you see what your game plan is
and then he goes to work and he's and
he's got that Holloway thing where he
would go 60 in the first two rounds
intentionally and then he'll go Full
Throttle three four five and he'll just
eat you he's a problem yeah
well sugar can do is get pinned against
the cage and then if you talk about
knockout power I I'd love to hear the
disagreement that Peter Young doesn't
have more knockout power than Shogun so
perion starts some top level guys yeah
he starched uh starched Uriah with that
kick but he hit him with some nuclear
shots first
I get there you go oh no no no no dude
if this it stopped and I poke I'm gonna
[ __ ] oh my God I'm gonna walk out
I like that idea though straight left
lead just trying to go down the Miller
for O'Malley yeah Peter's throwing a lot
of kicks too I guess you really don't
have to worry about getting taken down
too so these kicks are just open for
business
boy I tell you what do you want to talk
about Focus individual look at Sugar
yeah Focus sharp Anthony uh Anthony told
me that him and Anthony and his coach
told me Anthony Smith okay they trained
with Sean and they both were like he's
like they were very complimental oh nice
that was classic oh
I like this sugar yeah yeah Focus sugar
shine
the MMA Guru who did a great breakdown
on this he said I like him yeah I like
him too he talks [ __ ] sometimes but he's
[ __ ] hilarious he's like uh but he
said he thought that um the
he thought that O'Malley was going to
win the first round and then Midway
through the second Peter was going to
catch him I didn't see that yeah yeah
oof Peter playing Chiefs yeah you don't
want to get hit with that [ __ ] shot
especially because even just the
musculature of of O'Malley like you know
having a thicker muscle you know helps
you absorb a little bit more damage yeah
all those tendons and nerves and you
know are more exposed
I was curious about if people yeah the
over under there was a prop bet over
under on takedowns for Peter Young was
too
oh man I'll take that over all day
really yeah sure I was like yeah I don't
know man for the whole fight for the
three or two takedowns two takedowns
over under like so yeah I mean but for
the whole fight yeah I'm pretty sure
what was it plus what I don't know
because someone asked me about it no I
did say this on the shop show I I said
period I think it's gonna be a little
surprised how good how hard uh sugar is
to take down yeah it's takedown
defensive words on it Non-Stop and I've
heard his jits is really good I mean
I've never seen it in a fight but like
yeah what a big moment for sugar for
sure but yeah Anthony and
um
they said that he's like all business
like asked tons of questions he's like
super humble and he's doing great chat
boxing right now yeah he really is his
movements even straight line Focus chins
down hands up that left hand's up oh
oh he's gonna get him down here yeah I
would assume he can get him down here
yeah there's one for you
and it wasn't it wasn't available on
mine
oh that's ballsy
the period doesn't need to be careful
because Sean does have a long frame and
he's okay suspicions in the bottom yeah
I don't like you going for submissions
that close to the cage yeah
break the grip drop a leg between the
legs you got to get up because what's
the deal right there see how you broke
and got up that's what you should do
when you go to the cage you can't fight
Jiu Jitsu on the ground when your heads
that close the kitchen you lose the
ability to Pivot which I can't go from
one side to the next side so now I got
one ear stuck Against the Cage it limits
you dude it literally takes away all the
times I've seen you like injure someone
it was in the center of the cage now you
think about it yeah
that's why a lot of guys who aren't
versus Jiu Jitsu will crawl back to the
cage and use it to get up yeah
it's a good sign if you're a sugar fan
that he was able to get up though yes
yeah
oh that's a good shot he's doing
phenomenal here I I think
you see that in that takedown I mean oh
that's a tougher yeah if you probably
give it to Peter right I don't know man
I give it to O'Malley
just just watching the end right there I
was saying like if O'Malley continues to
have success there's going to be a phase
where Peter gets frustrated and starts
going [ __ ] Tasmanian there was more
of those for him yeah it's not like
Peter dancing on the ground yeah I mean
the kicks were vicious yeah but I mean
to a judge they just don't respect the
kicks the same way yeah it just doesn't
the biggest thing in the the round was
the takedown they overvalue those
remember that one yeah especially I
don't even do anything with it like
sugar was able to get back to his feet
he got a little ground pound down there
I can see I give the sugar got that
first round it's gonna be talking how do
you guys think they should actually like
if there was like a coherent scoring
system
how do you think they should score just
the takedown like that if they always be
worth much taking somebody down yeah
they don't Advance like if we were
striking or not like you throw a jab and
I take your back I hit a good corner on
you I was like and then I hit you with a
jab it's like oh you I'm like well I
didn't do nothing with that angle you
got credit for the gem but I also think
you got to know the fighters too so if
you have a guy who's versus Jiu Jitsu so
sugar Shawn throwing those submission
attempts he gets no points for that
because judges don't understand Jiu
Jitsu yeah so him being the offensive
even though he's on his back he should
still be able to win yeah
or at least get some points
but they don't
they say I mean they say they score
submission attempts but it doesn't seem
like that I mean Peter's coming out like
a [ __ ] Russian spark plug here
whoa it just backs up those and that was
Tiger he frames so he has holes yeah
move his head so he gets comfortable
come on she'll get that rock though got
him he got him go get that come on get
him come on he's hurt he's hurt oh oh he
got his neck no stand the feet sugar
be careful though he's gonna come out so
he's rushing right so but he's hurt he's
hurt don't let him get
oh
that was a big shot
I'm driving to take down here good job
your knees uh
you got another takedown but sugar did
have wobble yeah
he rocked sugar right they did they did
they're even on the scoreboard you got
the takedown so then you probably
favored Peter yeah right now if you're a
judge though that was clear at the end
the round would end right now Peter is
back up and we're only a minute in two
dollars I mean they're one start shot a
piece yeah man some big shots
yeah he just have to he has to because
Peter's smaller has to navigate those
long limbs yeah
so jealous of guys that are built like
that in Jiu-Jitsu
I will never [ __ ] triangle anybody
ever
it's not for you
oh oh armbar
does he have the No No his right foot's
not in the position to climb down in the
back yeah
oh you're dropping elbow get up get up
walk to the cage get up no don't hit a
switch just get some wrist control go to
all four knees live so like you turtle
from there yeah I'm big on teaching the
turtle and knee slide get your base
under you yeah control wrists get up to
your feet you know what I mean and then
if you drive too hard on that then we
could talk about you know a reversal or
a sweep or submission off of it but I
I'm a firm teacher because I didn't do
that for most my career I only only uh
submitted or swept from the bottom now I
added scrambling or you know stand up so
if you create that kind of scramble
people have to engage you more to hold
you down well that engagement causes you
not to have your balance proper and I
can sweep you or catch you in a
submission whereas if you just have to
worry about not being swept or submitted
hell I can roll the best juicy guys in
the world if you say okay just stay on
top and don't get submitted all right
you know but don't engage I'm like all
right if I don't have to engage
it slipped sure yeah it looked like you
tripped him going backwards
oh what are you doing careful but
careful let's not get too creative to
that one stick to that
is this you just jab and just there's an
uppercut there if you want jab right
hand jab upper Cub jab overhand yeah
just see where the fit the hole so I
think he throws a jab it'll bring up
Peter yawn's defense he can go ahead and
time the next shot
and also to your point with Peter's uh
framing there's an uppercut there yeah
and he can't see it yes he's blinding
himself to it that's why you just can't
well
predictable yeah he's only really thrown
the one two here
as he's coming over the frame under the
frame yeah the uppercut's there oh
credit where credit's due this is
playing out pretty much exactly how
[ __ ] Guru said thus far
now to also be fair remember peon's the
number one best weight in the world oh
totally sugar Shawn's the real deal no
matter what happens in this fight he's
landed on him he's been oh he's heard
him that's the most hurt I've ever seen
Peter on a microphone
I've never have you ever seen him get
rocked and look at O'Malley just
stealing their [ __ ] banging dude
yeah there is a way where sugar loses
fight but still doesn't lose his
absolutely yeah no because of the
credibility of the fighting of Peter if
he goes out there and it's competitive
like how it is right now yeah he goes
the decision yeah oh yeah he goes on for
the score yeah they have to find a top
you know I mean even at this point if he
gets caught with a knockout I think he's
moved up totally agree I think he's
already improved by far the toughest
distance
yeah number 11 he's always in this fight
his only ranked opponent he looks tired
though Pedro yeah he is tired
Beyond's putting that [ __ ] Pace on
him yeah
yeah John's winning this round yes for
sure
and yawn doesn't look very tired either
which is no remember Jan's used to have
five rounds so threes walked in the park
for this guy even yeah he's gonna go
back right now and go [ __ ] I only have
one more round yeah three more yeah I
bet he comes out like a Russian band
yeah I think the next round will be
rough yes he's gonna unleash the gasket
and you're right look at O'Malley's
breathing right now yeah he's breathing
really hard yeah he's blowing he's
trying to get his cardio back
it's the first tough test it's just
about how much is he gonna have left now
in the third against eight yeah
he could just get back on his bicycle
like he was keep that distance with that
jab and just fire off that rear hand
Jesus yawns a [ __ ] monster man
but think about the guys
you know and then you give him this yeah
oh
I can't believe he ate that shot that
was a rough shot how about the chin on
sugar
that's the sweet oh that's a sick sweet
oh sick
let me landscard that's why sugar tried
that back great he hid that kid
he literally threw a slap out there I
can see how it's two two zero for Peter
on it could be one one maybe you know it
could be one one Frank thought sugar
maybe maybe we got that first round I I
think Sean O'Malley might have got the
first round too yeah I think he's
definitely lost it so let's say it's 1-1
because that wasn't a senate around see
if one one going the third yeah sign me
up let's go
best bad it's just so like when I really
want to go it's now I really want to
O'Malley you know but it looks
completely recovered look his mouth's
closed wow
God damn Beauty Online a big shot
yeah sugar looks all right here yeah no
totally recovered yeah it shows us in
great shape yeah breathing hard because
he's in a hard fight you know what I
mean like yeah he's he's in a straight
up fight yeah adrenaline guy swinging
like he is dude he can throw that
there's a jab line that rear hand up
that front kick that he throws the solar
plex he can throw from either side he's
[ __ ] awesome I think you're almost oh
my God that was filthy 2018 yawn and
Molly is definitely more tired heading
to the final
2018 yawn turn up the heat oh man to go
out on the shield in this third John
wins a forensics like around 10-9 after
the fight tied 19. there you go Kevin
dude O'Malley is a [ __ ] badass dude
yeah he's definitely not losing any
credibility he could get starts right
now and he's 100 percent
you know for anybody saying it was
overrated or you know no I think I'm
like right now man he is going he's in a
close fight yep with the number one guy
yeah I mean you two and Kevin aioli
who's you know as credentialed as they
come have it 1-1
in that but I can see how you guys think
it just depends on how much they score
the the takedown you actually want to
see the fight count yeah we didn't do
much with the takedown no I know
now I'm predicating that first round off
how these judges great angles yeah that
was a nice views there you go
maybe keeps this up well I gotta be
honest I thought Peter Young was gonna
apply a little more impression in this
third round I do too he's oh he might be
saving it a little bit too
oh god oh
well this can be dicey
good balance nice oh
that hurt oh that hurt him oh going back
oh that cut up that opened him up come
on sugar uppercut daddy uppercut bro oh
let's get him get on the knees get on
the middle the uppercut's there as well
dude that knee is so mean of the middle
yeah it's a great length for it oh
It's just sometimes he throws his
punches too high good job yeah you got
color heavy left hook there he sometimes
throws his punches too wide and Peter
sits there is inside the punch so
they're throwing punch we're punching oh
Peter also has the speed good sprawl
almost good
get off the ankle come on good wrist
control I'm telling you Sean's no punk
when it comes to the no the cage
great awareness put pressure on the head
great underhook now keep the hands from
getting connected
that's an easy fight to win with one leg
pull your knee to the ground or he's
gonna do a jump uh knee here it's a big
wrist you need to take him down but I
bet you he does
I'll be Let It Go
oh come on two minutes left
oh that what's up with that Guillotine
daddy oh he's gonna sit up oh no no uh
oh he's been fighting so perfect why
would you do that
and that blood is Peter John you know
that you know that's going to slip off
and it wasn't like it was cinched before
you drop I'll drop on a guillotine but
it cinched before I fall it's got a
Kimura
but not yeah but it's not gonna be
enough and where he is right now the
shoulder pressure from Peter he can't
even turn the corner to jump out there
you go and fight hand fight he's got
that wrist control on the far side
though spin
oh sorry I keep turning away oh sorry no
that's me oh it's you
don't do this motion though Jenny you
know there you go I'm like what are we
doing right now I had a boy
and he just marches forward oh Peter's
tired too though man oh yeah we got that
uppercut come on John straight down the
pipe dude
that knee was that knee would have
[ __ ] decapitated oh
you think Sean won the fight I think so
foreign
[ __ ] no
I still think he's up this round yeah I
think so too if he gets taken down it
could be kind of getting really hard to
deal with don't do nothing good job get
up
40 seconds sugar let's do it Daddy
that perion's eye is [ __ ]
dude front kick up the middle put the
ball of your foot in his chin when's the
last time you saw Peter you're on this
beat up never never ever ever
oh don't run into him no no
what are we doing
that oh
I still think Sean won this round yeah
but you made it much harder for the
judges now damn it but three takedowns
I don't know man get no but like give me
the let me see that let me see the get
up Sean act like you won
that D was brutal and he was brutal bro
I think uh just won that fight I I
personally if I was a judge he won the
fight dude
I mean like who did more damage Sean
landed a lot more shots and made us all
yeah I got one for Peter and there was a
couple of the third round but not the
damage and now the judges are supposed
to predicate off damage right yeah like
damage is the first indicator yeah and I
this knee dude biggest shot of the fight
by far boom yeah and that that's the
third round let's him open look at him
hurt him with a shot boom yeah
oh that one was bad yeah that that put
him oh
yeah Sean's not used to people being
able to like counter that fast yeah this
fight should be a five round I know dude
imagine if it's five rounds somebody's
getting finished I think Peter knows
look at him
I just think he's not sh like I think he
didn't think this fight was gonna be
that tough dude 100 yeah I think Peter
Johnson
like look no matter what happens man oh
man
I'm now on board though he's sugar
thinks he lost the fight and I hope he
wins you think he just give to him I I
don't think his judges can give it to
him I hope you guys are right though
no no absolutely not okay
according to the judges the it's
supposed to be damage done that's the
number one indicator it's no longer the
ultimate takedown now listen to it you
listen to us
are you listening to it I'm glad I'm
glad that we couldn't hear the announcer
so we're like you know we're
uninfluenced by the announcers
what a [ __ ] fight man
do you think sugar Shan's the real deal
now
okay
give it to him boy you know what he made
a fan out of me how could you not be
yeah he belonged to the top five 100 I
don't think you dropped him from
Millennium no way he has to move up you
think
it's a split decision
it's a split decision yeah
I called him yeah let's go dude one time
yep give it yeah baby give it to him
wrong in our prediction leading up to it
I I thought Jesus eon's got [ __ ] three
times in a row though I mean
he's he's the most dangerous guy who's
ever a pre-fight skid ever rocket ship
on suga's backpack
wow he's fighting for the title now yeah
I'm the winner of the TJ algerman 100
guarantee he has to guaranteed that's
all he needed was the legitimate fight
you know what I mean wow
he was huffing in the second dude he
came out in the third and put it on him
like he did he pieced him up
he used his length his distance his
footwork yeah and then it's great
because I mean he had that long jab that
was just snaking out like a tongue but
then would line up and it kept his eyes
open for that right hand yeah
said he didn't know
that's and that's exactly if you're a
sugar Shawn fantasy exactly what you
want you want a tough fight you don't
want to be going the instruction because
we're not going to learn anything about
sugar you want him and this is what we
wanted at the Pedro million's fight we
didn't get so you see the real
nitty-gritty of sugar Sean what's past
the test what's he built out of the
amount of wrestling
wow really of course she's gonna wrestle
you dude never really hurt but a little
rock wants yeah that's fair yeah I think
you just got rocked the one time in the
second round wow
dude other than that the shots I mean he
caught him a good shots but I don't
think anyone really hurt nothing was
more devastating that's by far the
biggest moment in the fight I feel a
little bit sick for Peter yon given the
last three fights have they gone for him
oh wow this one legitimately at least
yeah yeah I think the first two that he
lost on the skip you know we can make
arguments about it yeah yeah
wow I'm dying he's gonna be the talk of
UFC 280 no matter what happens get get
you on a win and then let him let him
win the title and let's do the rematch
five rounds for the for the bill
deserves a title shot says he thinks
people want him to fight for it you know
who's I guarantee listen he has no say
in the matter I was just gonna say yeah
the UFC gave him the number one guy and
Peter John was his biggest test
the issue now if your sugar Sean fan is
he fights the winner of TJ and Al
Jermaine the only caveat where you could
see Peter on when that fight was
grappling was his issue you know who's a
better Grappler than Peter Young TJ and
algerman I mean there's debate whether
algerman's better but against sugar
algerman's going to be a problem for him
so is TJ as far as the wrestling goes
Jesus Christ dude I gotta check my bets
what's up fellas I gotta check my bets
because I got parlays with Sean that are
I can't dude I can't believe
what a big win you uh said you uh that
anyone's going for Peter John in here
your goddamn terrorists
I was I thought you know hey proven
commodity yeah I'm with you by that you
know I mean like there's just some
questions we need to answer but that's
answered them it's a perfect example
though like when I was trying to
handicap this fight TJ and the main
event you're like I don't [ __ ] know
man yeah like all three all three of
them are impossible
Oh Oh I thought that was the
yeah I'm a big tattoo even as a fan I
was at uh I was at 271 when he starts
Derrick Lewis in that elbow
that was bananas he came out to Spice
Girls and then started Steve Lewis in
his own in his hometown with an elbow
boy what a bunch of fights I'll tell you
what I'm curious
let us know but I bet you these boys are
an alpha brain listen I'm talking about
Onyx the best nootropic on the planet
they got that Alpha Brain if you haven't
heard of it Alpha Brain is caffeine free
and here's how confident on is about
their Alpha Brain product you can pick
it up at Walmart if you want to go to
Walmart but you don't need to go there
if you go to audit.com CFC all right on
it.com CFC you save 10 off the best
nootropic on the planet or you can pick
it up at Walmart but definitely use that
promo code to help your boy out get the
best nootropic on the planet they're so
confident in how what good this
nootropic is it's money back guarantee
if you don't like it no return necessary
you keep it they give you your money
back but I guarantee you're gonna like
it Alpha Brain the only nootropic you
should be using on the planet get your
mind right get in the zone two little
pills you're in the zone next thing you
know you're making moves like Steve Jobs
you can go to onnit.com CFC you save 10
off all supplements and workout gear at
on it.com slash CFC get you some Alpha
Brain the best nootropic on the planet
baby
wow what a freaking win for sugar Sean I
can't believe that he I mean going into
the third round nuts who's who's picking
him going in the third round not me
because I thought Peter arms came out
like a banshee but yeah apparently
through the punches you know the and
then the knee in the third was a big
deal wore Peter not out wow those long
guys like like O'Malley when they throw
a knee up the gut like that it just
looks like it's
I'm jealous of his of his ability to
like be so [ __ ] long it looks like
he's gonna decapitate someone with that
thing
and all he did was split his face open
man yeah Peter John was believing men
what is this what do you do with yawn
you have like so let's say let's say
a matter of fact I think Yan you just
have him fight whoever loses this fight
regardless you'd have yawn fight TJ if
we were to lose that's a great fight
yeah and then listen sugar was like I
don't know if I deserve it cool dude
you're fighting the winner for sure
there's the only reason they're not they
want you to be the the champion that the
only reason they gave you pee on is
because you're this massive star you
know and you ranked 11 you get the
number one guy the only option is the
title shot there's gonna be a [ __ ]
rocket on the back of his back now and
the UFC is gonna put him into a
Stratosphere that we haven't seen before
yeah and we and to be honest we needed
it 100 dude guys like you and me we need
it we needed it we need somebody to talk
we need he's American who people can
really do he has [ __ ] pink hair God
bless anyone like that yeah come on the
answer to all questions you think the
kid can fight now it's better than if he
starts from I think honestly agree it
answers way more questions and and I
always I'm hesitant to co-sign a guy
until I see see him really face some
adversity because we haven't seen sugar
yeah they tried it they tried the Cheeto
fight right his leg gave out they tried
in the Pedro Munoz fight that didn't
happen yeah now you got TJ dilstraw Al
Jermaine Sterling the winner of this
gets to fight the biggest star in
bantamweight history do you know how
much sugar you know how much money this
this fight just became for that belt
with pay-per-view products [ __ ]
O'Malley this they like they just threw
three million dollars in the middle of
that thing dude Big Boy fight big boy I
don't know how sugar sounds like I need
to see if I deserve a tie shot it don't
matter daddy you're getting it no matter
what you couldn't talk your way out of
it you could talk your way out of it TJ
for Suga all the [ __ ] talk oh my God
sign me up give it to me
doing like uh now now let me ask you
this is let's say
who who's who is a tougher uh of a
matchup for sugar Shawn Peter Yan TJ
dillashell or Al Jermaine they're all
[ __ ] tough I think TJ you think it's
just movement
I just think algeman I think Al Jermaine
is going to shoot on him quicker yeah
he's up there and I think we'll play
games
I think the length and power that no
here's the thing for sugar and he passed
the test but enough of her easy fights
like there's no walk in the park for him
those days are those days are over but
those big lanky guys when they got a
bunch of advantages on the ground they
also have disadvantages with a big ass
[ __ ] neck and and Al Jermaine
strangled sandhagen in two seconds when
he got his back he hits your back you're
in trouble yeah unless you're Peter John
he had his back for a little bit 30
minutes that's because John's built like
like me you just go like this yeah
man sugar Woman made my freaking day
that was it gave me all the energy
amazing because I did not think he was
gonna win that fight neither did I and I
definitely didn't think he was gonna win
after that second round
yeah that is gonna be in trouble man I
was like yeah because I gave you on the
second round dude yeah and I was like oh
man the way he's yeah he's making up see
you know I had it because that you know
I was
I always swaying more towards the
takedown so I I had it 2-0 going that
third round but like but when Kevin
aioli who I respect so much than you two
we're just getting to Sugar I'm like oh
maybe he might do it dude I was 50 50 on
the first round I really was like first
round could win either way man maybe
Sean I just didn't think the tank down
counts for anything yeah you know I just
really don't I think the Judge is
starting to see it that way too it can't
just be a takedown competition yeah if
you don't do anything with it if you
don't do nothing with it don't count I
mean and then you don't land nothing you
don't do anything of significant you
don't cause any damage no Panic yeah I
mean and the other guy it's like well
what did you really do you took them
down all right cool you know a lot of
times I I notice no nothing else happens
yeah what twice and then with the knee
which is the most devastating yeah yeah
blow of the match I give it to sugar and
it should have been five rounds to be
honest it should have been and I think
it will be next I think should have
could have finished him with five rounds
I think so too it would have been the
opposite of my thought process yes
leading up to it me too yeah I'd have
been like oh no five rounds
oh [ __ ] I know five rounds was actually
would have waited uh he can be that
exhausted and he can go sit on a chair
for a minute and come out solid yeah to
recover like that that's why UFC is the
best sport in the world man it's just
there's all these like outliers you
never know who's gonna show up you never
know what's gonna happen NFL NBA kinda
know what's gonna happen here no way
dude in like uh
and
I sometimes when I'm the first time I
watch a fight like when I watch a fight
live if I'm really emotionally invested
in one of the guys winning I notice that
I lean towards interpreting it as the
other guy winning just I think like I'm
like just out of anxiety you know but
that's why I think uh it just every time
yawn would land on like oh [ __ ] I felt
like he's gonna knock him out but
yeah well you know he got him really I
mean from what we saw here I only saw
one shot really hurt O'Malley that was a
big shot it was a big shot shot but all
the other ones I mean it removed him but
like they weren't devastating yeah and
there was several shots from O'Malley
that hurt yeah you know what I mean your
boys had him rocking and then backwards
and then also and I've never seen Peter
ever get hit yeah I didn't actually run
back I mean back away
that's true he was he was hurt
two at least two times where yep yeah
the knee hurt him and the left hand
heard him back and just you know and
those are winning things in the round
you know what happened that round well
someone so got rocked I'm like all right
well God we got we still got two big
boys fights and you know the two titles
lines do TJ shows up dude he never
misses like he shows his big fight he
[ __ ] shows up
come on TJ let's now I'm two for one on
my picks two out of three ain't bad dude
I gotta check my channel
any uh favorites going into this TJ
algebrae fight
Frank I got TJ yeah I got TJ too Jessie
TJ TJ TJ all around here big TJ but I'm
definitely very much the only cat I've
got here is uh you know TJ's not as
active as you'd want yeah
it's the other thing that no one's
really talking about too is like
he's coming back off reconstructive knee
surgery like he did get his his
ligaments torn in his last fight yes of
course yeah
powerful Dwayne I'm sure he's fine I'm
sure he you know oh he's a knight yeah
and also the because the advancement in
technology with like the when you tear
your ACL MCL it ain't [ __ ] now really no
NFL running backs used to be a career
Ender now they're bouncing back six
months later stronger faster than ever
ever says Adrian Peterson who's the
first one everyone's all what the [ __ ]
he doing yep yeah
TJ I remember like the guy who did who
did I think it was Adrian Peterson and
then also did Kobe's uh Achilles Francis
went to see that guy before his serial
fight and they got that doctor the guy
did like he's like the top he was like
he can't fight dude like he can't
[ __ ] fight and then Francis wasn't
fought anyway anymore nuts yeah yeah the
UFC sends all their like top boys to
that to that guy I think I think that
one was it was someone that like Mark
Helen then brought to external it was
like the UFC guy either all hey man you
know you're clear like you're fine just
go ahead and fight we're gonna
bury you underneath a yeah
come on TJ let's go
he looks calm
yeah he's been here before I mean they
both have been you know such a good
fight yeah
that's the other thing about this fight
too like like you said like these guys
are both been in these massive five
round title fights multiple not one
multiple Islam is his first one correct
yeah and the the the knock on him is he
doesn't show up to his full potential
when there's that many eyeballs on him
Islam yeah like in training they're like
dude we've never seen anything like it
you just he hasn't adapted that like the
the bigger the stage he kind of shuts
down a little bit so there's something
to be said about that yeah Gamers yeah
yeah exactly so that doesn't show up
game day some guys can't yeah I bet you
there's a correlation between guys that
don't like where you stick a microphone
in front of them and they're kind of
like I would rather not be doing this
and
huge huge fights in front of a bunch of
people it's kind of the same thing well
it's like khabib if he has that
legendary line where Islam is his first
Main Event you know when you you know
there's been anybody when you're in the
main event you gotta do more press you
can't you gotta sell the card so he's
doing you know 30 interviews in a row
and he's sitting there and it's behind
the scenes the theme's on UFC embedded
and he's like oh man I'm so sick of this
I don't want to do anymore and khabib
goes oh this is easy my friend just lose
this all goes away just if you don't
want to do it just lose tonight oh he
goes loose tomorrow night all this goes
away it's very easy my friend just lose
all you do is lose and this all goes
away [ __ ] great you're right man all
right yeah
he's like just lose this goes away if
you don't like it just lose the fight
tomorrow night
it all goes away that's interesting
because I hadn't really thought about I
wonder what the dynamic between those
two is like because they were pupils
together for so long and then now
khabib's kind of talking about two
different guys though I think it's
unfair to Islam where he's next khabib
and even Islam's like I'm not khabib I'm
a different thing like he does some
things better than Kabir he does stand
us better his movement's better by far
khabib's ground and pounds more vicious
khabib's trying to break you I think
Islam's submissions Islam submissions
are better uh you know what I don't know
I I think actually could be might be a
little I don't know but that inverted
triangle could be engaging it's funny
yeah and so so
but I do think actually Islam's
takedowns are better like I think
sometimes habib's takedowns are from
determination and balls and guts yeah
like there's times I mean like he's
taking some shots at him like that's not
a great shot yeah I mean head down arms
up yeah but he finishes him he has that
belief in himself that I'm going to
finish the shot and I'm Gonna Make It
Happen whereas uh you know Islam is much
more technical I think with his
wrestling when khabib fought Conor who
are you guys rooting for Connor I never
moved again I've never rooted against
God but I could be yeah
Connor did much better than I expected
dude in fact when people were talking
about Patty fighting grappling tape I'm
like bro
it took four rounds for one of the best
Grapplers in the world in MMA to get
Conor and finish him I mean yeah he took
him down and couldn't do much with him
you know what I mean like in fact in the
third round even see I think could be
kind of panic a little bit you know what
I mean like I was sitting there I could
sit and go whoa you know because you
know Connor's take down defense and even
when he got taken down his ability to
control wrist and frame walk to the cage
yeah he did a lot of good stuff more
success against khabib than anybody
right and I think khabib actually like
he stopped khabib's ground and pound
better than anybody okay you know I'm
sitting there going wow guys because he
was always winning them all you're right
but he's not winning how he thinks he's
not dominant and there's doubt going in
his mind right now and here's the other
thing you know I know I'm a big kind of
Dick writer the other thing kind of
really being trained for that fight
that's what I guess that's important is
that true like yeah that's massive
because he did phenomenal in the fight
so that's why anybody talking about oh
we'll just take I'm like guys Connor
like it's not that easy no yeah I mean
like he was that Reckless like he didn't
he wasn't he didn't like his Camp was
not a proper Camp no he's dealing with
[ __ ] yeah I was just saying not out of
choice but more of just you know yeah he
had just made 100 million dollars yeah
but you know there's other stuff yeah
party hard man
did you celebrate now Frank when you in
your in your like hey dude I'm talking
the Frank mayor days the legend of the
UFC the face of the UFC did you ever
were you ever get big head and go out
and party before big fights no you're
always discipline no your dad probably
went like yeah yeah his dad was his
coach and luckily too I got married at a
young age you know what I mean so like
you know having a wife at home to kind
of answer I think sometimes when you
have the type of Personality that I have
I kind of need somebody who's kind of
like you know hey you know like yeah
yeah you're not I need someone to be
there when I open up the door at four in
the morning and like where have you been
you know four in the afternoon you know
from the next night yeah you're fighting
Tim Sylvia into it yeah and this
probably wasn't the best idea dude my
one of my favorite moments ever from
anyone's career was was in yours when uh
when you kick the kick the pills and you
said beforehand where you were like I'm
[ __ ] bad because I knew what that's
like and I was like I could just see I
was like prescription pills like that's
kind of struggled yeah
do you still have them what no I avoid
them like the place yeah me too but I
have surgeries and stuff so I still I
still have a lot I'd be lying to you to
say that I haven't yeah yeah me too but
like you know I just it's a battle
constantly yeah I mean like because yeah
because also too I live in a world where
surgeries injuries you have a doctor hey
man like if you want to sleep tonight I
mean like what are you going to do we
just replaced your neck yeah or you know
I mean go to Disneyland with the kids
you know I mean I'm sitting there going
well I can you know be miserable I don't
walk around the stupid wheelchair
pushing me around I refuse to be in a
scooter so then I'm sitting there like
on a cane and I'm sitting there and then
my personality then it's like well I'm a
miserable [ __ ] right now I'm not
enjoying myself or I could take this
pill and everything the problem is that
if I could just take one or two and I
but that's what suckers me and I will
for a little while I'll do one or two
and just one or two I know we always
overdo it right and then all of a sudden
it's like well [ __ ] at four just today
and then all of a sudden before you know
it it's like all right well now you're
doing like 20 a day it's a good all
right the good thing is actually like I
know you talked about the company that
here is Kratom you know I have do my own
it's a different but Kratom itself is
really helpful creative is phenomenal
you know I mean I know the big Pharma
tries to bad mouth a bit like you know
they're not there's no one's overdeen on
kratomy no correct if you take more than
you're supposed to you just feel sick
yeah actually my friends have taken too
much you vomit yeah so like or you have
to go and get narcane in your nose or
you do what 400 000 people this year
have died from opiate someone's Narcan
from from not from
you're saying like you're saying from
the other [ __ ] like no from the other
shoes
but to that point with those painkillers
like Galaxy you know Cody and all that
stuff like we're wired it's like well
two feels good you know what you feel
about in two four yeah
me neither no man it's just not you're
not the kind of guy that goes and fights
[ __ ] lions and you're a moderate guy
yeah hey you know what would be sensible
I'm like what makes you think I'm a
sensible [ __ ] yeah
I'm just talking to sigura because he
had this uh we're big car guys I have
this Porsche GT2 RS and I tuned it which
is it's you shouldn't touch that car
because there becomes like a banshee and
Tom had the Porsche guy on and Tom's
like I have this buddy and he has a GT2
on this thing guys like oh one of the
best cars you can have you think he Tony
he's like why the [ __ ] would he do it
Tom's like I don't know so I called Tom
I'm like dude I do it because I don't do
anything normal like if there's any
wiggle room I'm gonna take it here we go
oh here we go and they're both so high
both of them are like oh you're gonna
put the pace on me dude this card's been
freaking good
a lot of light kicks
somebody's about to get dropped yeah
these boys are pretty reckless oh oh wow
that they ripped would you say what
needed
oh look at him it's going for the dude
he is a back Hunter yep
I didn't like when he had his leg there
TJ was going for the punch oh wait what
TJ's face is grimsing there oh [ __ ] he's
hurt dude
could he have blown his knee yeah we had
one leg up he's he's hurt oh [ __ ] he's
hurt it's over
oh we're not fishing out the right way
oh no I think he's introduced oh I think
no that's giving the worst thing for guy
I know they remind me if you pick my
phone I'm out or just jump to your ass
you know what I mean he shouldn't have
bounced around and fought
boys
this is the worst spot you could be yeah
yeah you're in Mount with your head
against the cage dry with four minutes
left and then you know if you turn five
or four minutes
I think we just marked them all yeah she
had two by far worst case scenario yeah
and now he's getting almost in a gift
wrap and then you know with an act
that's his specialty and with an
undisclosed injury also most likely yeah
one's face is Grimson that is not good
yeah God look at that look at how game
he is though the fight's over with oh
[ __ ]
boy he is really lighting him up yeah
this is somehow he comes through this to
be honest I would give my back here I
would give my back and take my chance of
stopping it boy I think TJ has a really
bad injury this is not TJ
how's your man gets a body trying on you
you ain't going [ __ ] nowhere my God
he's being he's flattened about like
there's there's nowhere for him to go
see I'd rather have this because they're
about to stop the fight does he have it
no but now he's gonna have to fight this
for three [ __ ] three minutes your jaw
just getting torqued on you know what
though at least it's off his ribs a
little bit
but the mount driving down it was
nothing
I'd much rather be here this dude Matt
that I train with takes my back [ __ ]
100 of the time when I roll them and
shout out to Matt dude shout out to Matt
elbow control he cross-faced choked me
this week where I literally attacked
because I thought he was gonna pop my
fake teeth out of my head man I hope he
has oh no man TJ I I keep giving my back
and hand fighting he could oh go go go
go yep
when a guy has a body triangle like that
that's the only thing sometimes if a guy
goes a bump you end up getting put to
your back because now you can't remove
the triangle so it's almost kind of like
you're too attached to him great but if
he rotates too hard and leg slips and
you're on bottom so explain that to me
how to like so like he goes on a body
triangle right now here see how he's
pushing him down he actually threw him
to his ribs if he can cut his left arm
across as he's pushing and he gets that
elbow in there then he's on top and
mount and top inside his clothes guard
inside of the truck inside his legs yep
so what I want to do with a triangle
what I do with anybody everybody
triangles I just I turn and pull the
knee so instead of the I don't want my I
don't want your shin across my ribs
right like see how this [ __ ] right there
yeah so like my right hand would grab
his knee and Pull and twist towards it
now you can't choke me because now I'm
shoulder on you we're off
but see how like right the body if if
the if the if that leg that's the
triangling leg you know uh across the
body see how it's there locked he needs
to grab the ribs and turn
both feet flat on the ground and rotate
up towards these turning the wrong way
something's going on so when you say
pull you're talking so take the knee and
Pull It in the direction of the of the
ankle yes and then turn away from it so
that way you're pulling the knee from
the side of you almost Center Line so
that I can make it to where our backs
are not even I don't want my back
against your chest I want my shoulder
against your chest you can't choke me
wow wow dude and he's exhausted and
algeman's coming like a Tasmanian devil
something's going on with TJ yeah what
was that face he was making I don't know
but his movement's all I mean he fought
well I mean with torn ACL in his last
fight so
got algemane is a [ __ ] monster demon
Tasmanian Devil dude
oh let's see but I mean psychologically
I gotta be uh there's a flip side of
this
Al Jimmy and his brain thought this
fight was over with I just said the
fight was over with yeah
it was not looking good he could go back
to the stove like Jesus Christ yeah the
guy survived that oh my God you know
what I mean like I've been there before
you throw something in your Sunday Best
at somebody and they're still standing
there yeah it can kind of hurt you a
little bit like oh well [ __ ] dude you
hit a guy with every single thing you
have right on his chin and he just looks
at you I guess on the uh on the official
broadcast they said his shoulders out
his left shoulder is out see his
shoulder
right now
he is a [ __ ] Savage dude man just he
just enjoyed that one dislocated yeah
wow Savage now are they gonna pop it
back in
what a [ __ ] animal dude
it's in holy [ __ ] dude chance that thing
coming out it's pretty good they just
popped it back in
yeah you might have an AC separation too
AC joint right there where your clavicle
hooks the shoulder I've sprained that
before and it's not fun
yeah you play football everybody's done
it yeah I mean like it is awful did they
show when he did it here it's gonna be
here he's gonna land on his shoulder I
bet yeah I bet you you're right see I
hate how he was a handout that's what
did the seat oh and that's what he's
grimacing oh no it didn't look like it
oh but he he oh he yeah he did get up
kind of
is it back in it has to be he's moving
around he wasn't he was holding it
strange when he got up from that yeah
wow how bored is Steve Harvey damn
holy [ __ ] what a [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
hey TJ do me a favor fight Corey Santa
hanging number two in the world and then
blow out your knee and then try to win
that fight and then also fight for the
Beast find your life with one arm yeah
against a dude who takes two minutes
with one arm yeah one arm God damn dude
was he defending all that with one arm
yeah his left arm never he couldn't do
anything oh well I think his arm was in
there but he couldn't have had full
strength and survived that man now he's
lunging God dang it
he has that right hand he doesn't want
to throw out his left it's a game-bred
human right there yeah
he's gonna take him down every single
round dude like like he's best in the
first not quite as good as the second he
slows down
but look at like CJ's lunging in because
he's trying to get out and generated off
it Jesus Christ
this is just something this is a huge
grappling Advantage dude oh we got one
arm look at that shoulder dude
does it look like it's out again yeah it
does
the way he was punching was insane yeah
it must be her and he sold it tight and
then he was just lunging with the right
and he got taken down damn
now here's the thing this game plan
against sugar Sean's gonna be tough man
you know Jesus tough yeah with this
grappling
oh yeah Sean's gonna have to mix it it's
[ __ ] it's great algeman you're
calling sugar out right oh 100 sure you
don't want the guy to get any better no
yeah give me that money give me that
money give me he has all the attention
you need yeah you know he's only gonna
get better every fight right
man this is a nightmare for for O'Malley
though this fight because you know this
isn't a good fight for him yeah not from
what I'm saying because he's not even
have a length advantage on Sterling and
then the takedown so let's just keep
putting him on his back yeah Sterling is
explosive because you gotta get in the
distance Long Limbs and like you said
like yeah hey offensively that's great
for submissions
one of the hardest guys I've ever
there's a guy named Mike White that I
used to roll with I remember him yeah
one time sat down me and driza were
talking and I was frustrated I couldn't
tap him you know what I mean and usually
I could tap most people right I'm
sitting there going I cannot get this
mofo you know what's going on and drives
it goes I'm like Whitehead he's so bro
no one's tapped him get out of here I'm
like really you can't tap with me that
goes no he goes I had his back he put
both his hands down and pulled my feet
out like he reached down both hands he
goes no one does that to me I'm like oh
okay I don't feel so bad yeah yeah
he's like he just like what's your
what's your neck defense he goes yeah
he's like don't have neck don't have a
neck yeah my Whitehead was a monster
yeah in the gym monster
World beater
he just couldn't translate that to me
never quite the same yeah I mean he had
some good fights yeah but for the most
part no there were some times where it's
like man you know I mean who knows I
mean I'll shoot the guy would cut 70
pounds sometimes six weeks before five
years not for nothing chill may or may
not have said that about you to me yeah
you were the nastiest dude in the gym oh
wow yeah
yeah me and chill had some freaking
fights man
okay
dude TJ's I'd like to see jail fight
again he said he might fight Tito it
sounds like yeah that's who we are in
discussions after the freedom fight
night so oh really it'll be our first
show coming out with the United flight
league with the Harrison oh chill and
Tito would be with you guys yeah awesome
we're just trying to figure out a way to
make it you know
work for everybody I messaged him and
was like dude if you you go in there
with a bunch of jokes about Jenna
Jameson I was like that thing sells like
a [ __ ]
yeah how do you guys think that would do
I think it would do great if just just
like chill's got the biggest YouTube
video or YouTube channel in MMA yeah and
he's got highlights for days
yeah no chill on a mic is on on yeah
unmatched Tito ain't bad either no teal
just needs to play the heel this you
know I was starting to hear some others
Tito needs to play the heels WWE Trail
for the first time ever is going to be
you know the the nice guy but light him
up and Tito just plays the heels this
thing's gonna sell I think so and then
you put you put you and your and your
daughter on there yeah we're talking
later on though so me and my daughter
probably be a fight in June how old
should that be uh 19. it's a freshman do
you know about his daughters
Savage she's everything I am except for
discipline yeah also also better yeah we
can Market that well yeah I'm a pretty
sexy mofo dude I know I know I know I've
made a few men questions hashtag no Will
Smith here but no bar tractor
I'm not flying to Hawaii I'm feeling
occasionally [ __ ] my girl
yeah your daughter checks all the boxes
man 100 but she's doing a superstar she
has brains Have You Seen Her attributes
and then her coaches are her dad and
then her Grandpa yeah Savage and then
she wrestles at Iowa yeah yeah she's
Iowa wrestling coaches but her wrestling
coach too uh uh for government was great
you know yeah excuse me uh
the Bulldog Centennial your son uh plays
football Gorman right is that right yeah
linebacker yeah how long has she been
like
personally herself like self-motivated
all in on it oh from day one really it
was me trying to talk her out of it you
know what I mean yeah so uh I went away
if I had a daughter when did she start
well I want to start yeah I mean yeah
from infant changing diapers and put my
arm in there and she's like wrap her
arms around my arms drive her hips like
a little octopus it almost do like our
bed had a little post where you can like
you know like and I would have the kids
and hang on they're like six months old
I'm sitting like Jen look you know what
I mean yeah and they took it as a game
however they could hold themselves yeah
so from day one I have a video in fact I
probably should just do my phone we're
like Bella's probably about five years
old six maybe and I'm like where is she
goes she's in the front yard so we lived
in a cul-de-sac at the time I look out
Bella has two like duffel bags she's
filled up with [ __ ] she's picking them
up and she's sprinting in a circle by
herself through the culture how old is
she six years old Savage who the [ __ ]
even knows that they're supposed to
train cardio like that when they're six
well and I was kind of talking I was
like I thought I had one I'm like look
before the UFC had taken on the female
division like look Bella like you know
like be all my kids be martial artists
but like let's you know have you in
private school for a reason go be an
engineer let's do something like that
you know and then uh Ronda Rousey
screwed it up for me yeah yeah now it's
like she was like second highest paid
female you know female say goodbye yeah
exactly yeah as a female I'm like well
there goes that so I'm like all right
well I better go ahead and get on board
or this you know what I always say it's
like I need to be the captain of the
ship or I could watch it from the doctor
correct yeah
it's going I'd rather be on that boat
it's leaving the dock yeah I mean direct
about a little bit yeah I could be there
and go hey you know what no this was a
bad idea it's a good idea and so like
Bella like you know her mom's pretty
focused like that though better than I
am you know like very disciplined if you
say hey we're gonna do this we're gonna
do that with me I'm like I always the
joke I make in the household is like you
know like look the wheel was invented by
smart people we're lazy you know I mean
like yeah I always try to think of the
easiest way to do stuff which you know
sometimes for a fighter that's not the
best way to do things sometimes you have
to do things the hard way yeah Bella's
she takes the hard way yeah all three of
my kids they're like yeah cage and Ronan
same thing they lift in fact sometimes I
came from like really I almost people
think I play motivator I actually play
protector like even my youngest will be
at the gym and you know he's 95 pounds
and he's putting 135 on the deadlift I'm
like no there's bumpers for this and
he's okay you're allowed to do this for
three reps you know I mean also he's
rapping out six times I've actually had
to step on the weights and say stop yeah
you're gonna hurt yourself yeah I mean
like you know and all three of them are
like that it's just they're just like
you know they're just yeah your son's
wife is he a sophomore yeah yeah
he wants State already he's a wrestler
at 195 for the 4A I mean you're his dad
his kid's gonna be a problem yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome my my uh I like all
three of my daughters are in jits but
like but my oldest who's 10 is a [ __ ]
monster like she's but honestly it's
primarily because during the pandemic
when we were locked down and I you know
I was working from home I'm like oh well
I could I could take her every single
day she trained six days a week two
hours a day the entire year with us at
Caesar Gracie School
she got and she is ludicrous flexibility
she loves you and she's got Daddy's
ability to take punishment and so she's
like dude she's nasty the first
tournament that she I remember first
tournament she fought in I was like I
have no idea how it's gonna go because
you know during the pandemic there's no
tournaments right so you don't know what
she's gonna do and she armed barred the
chicken 20 seconds and I literally did I
could if if there would have been no one
around I'd have cried like a Baby Dude
like a baby it's good to see the kids
follow their dreams and hey case we
asked Mike what TJ saying
sugar Cheeto and Santa Hagen with a
bunch of shitty shitty puns
Al Jermaine did yeah
just give me the shooter fight
I like that I like that
I mean that was a straight beat down but
I'm curious what TJ's saying because
this is probably the as far as like
title aspirations this is probably it
for TJ I mean he'll be a perennial top
10 guy but it's probably end of the road
yeah is yours in bony outside
you have your own School in in Vegas
working on a syndicate with John Wood
yeah helping out there but yeah um but
maybe you open up my intervention in the
future but it's just hard to be a
full-time coach I'm really not I mean
hell sometimes I'm sending it I'm not
there for a month at a time
of combinations that I'm doing and stuff
and just traveling and whatnot
especially not with the FFN taking steam
yeah I'm I'm busy there yeah when Bella
was in town training for fights it was
easier for me because then I can like I
would actually sit there and say no to
things like well no I'm not gonna you
know because I'm gonna be there for
Bella that I'm training and stuff which
I don't like to be in the gym and not
train that's why it's hard if you're
injured like I'm just not that guy to go
to the gym no hello yeah I try to be I
tell them hey if you're hurt still show
up or I end up you know every time I'm
like sitting there limping around the
mat like what do you doing you know I
mean I'm training like what the hell are
you doing I'm like you know it's hard
not to try not to permanently injure
myself yeah TJ blue showed out in Camp
oh wow yes he came into the fight with
one Syndicate that's that's the that's
the Instagram where I saw Victor yeah I
think that's Victor's she's also he's
not retiring is he a lot of injuries
come they're building up for the knee
now the shoulder he's so [ __ ] sad
but you know what
algerman is a monster there could be a
worse guy to fight when you have a blown
out shoulder is Charles Oliveira
fighting islamakshev right now are we is
this actually happening this is like
actually happening
look at him dude and when he won the
title remember he was like he was a
paper champ the guy they took an illegal
knee everyone's all look at him carrying
the belt around look at him now dude
yeah yeah a lot of guys validation on
this card and you know Islam's the next
guy you know no matter what happens to
Charles Oliver he gets starts in three
seconds he's still one of the best to do
it he's validated Islam needs validation
Al Jermaine needs validation sugar Sean
needs validation
Bob Muhammad needs a validation I think
dude
but I'm trying to think of who
who's coming out of this thing shining
the the brightest sugar no matter what
sugar for sure but I just mean like
versus what their their potential was
and below's right there sugar for sure
but oh [ __ ] look at the thick Russian
himself Steven Seagal
he's pretty good
but volkanovsky they're talking about
volkanovski uh the rumor is is he gets
the next shot at 55. yeah
yeah I mean I think it probably depends
on what Chandler does like if Chandler
does something fantastic against Dustin
I'm sure they'll give it to him
vulcanovski'll be fun at 55. that would
be really fun I actually think Islam no
matter what happens in the fight I think
Islam is a better matchup for
volkanovsky I think Charles de Lavera be
a bit of a more dangerous fight for I
think so yeah vocadosi is interesting
though he's talking about uh because I
was telling him like you're 55 those
boys are big he's like dude all in my
training Partners I don't train with
anybody under 170 pounds well he used to
play rugby when he was what like 220
220. that's crazy
220 but he wasn't like some bodybuilder
220 or just yeah it was athletic
sprinting around
he was like the star of the like
Superstar was he geared up or what uh he
didn't say but he he was a superstar too
he wasn't like just a guy on the team he
was the Super he was like the study one
like the MVP of the league he drops 82
pounds but dude he was thick not like a
fun thick like his his cholesterol is
through the roof blood pressure probably
high but uh yeah you know he was saying
he was like dude but my he's like as far
as 55 he's like I'd have to go up to 170
for somebody stronger than me
starting to be a problem for me right
his kicks he does everything so well
yeah I see the number one pound per
pound like Camaro lost I think so
probably yeah thing is like slap contest
what hot promo Will Smith you imagine
dude you play The Fresh Prince song dude
I'm telling you that would be the best
investment
I'm kind of into this oh my God I don't
know if I can get behind this really
dude it's like I don't see I don't know
like I'm behind you like like you see
that I'm in did you see those slabs got
me into it yeah now listen I don't want
a press conference yeah I don't need a
press that's in that Square Garden for
these idiots but did you see that phone
booth fighting [ __ ] that like like very
recently where they actually had the
dudes fighting in a phone booth and went
viral on Instagram well that was Russia
right yeah yeah you gotta go to the
bathroom right now oh yeah I brought it
closer to it I was I was I looked at
that and I was like
I mean violence just for violent's sake
like if I see a you know like a video of
a fight in the street I'm all in you
know organized violence all in but like
organized violence in in a phone booth
I'm just kind of like well Russians are
just bored man they'll do the medieval
five on five they ever do that yeah
before I go that'd be kind of fun what
five guys you know what I'm saying
you're gonna pick four buddies yeah yeah
four buddies yeah and the over under
they're all how many broken limbs from
this guy against these opponents do you
see that there was one guy he had one
arm is is Russia clearly because there's
no commission if the guy had one arm and
it was him verse two guys and he just
went for one guy head kicked him ko'd
him they just carry him out then it was
one on one the guy with one arm just
beat the [ __ ] out of the dude one arm
just you imagine imagine like it's you
and your buddy are all all right well at
least there's two of us he starches your
buddy with the first shot you're all
there's four arms to one
dude [ __ ] you imagine though you're the
one guy getting started with one arm
yeah get back to the locker I'm like
he's like dude he's [ __ ] hate it
I thought he was gonna throw the left
dude
yeah
dude that's kind of rough to get your
ass beat by one arm man yeah especially
there's two of you right yeah yeah two
of you yeah actually that's like that's
a kind of like a gay porn career like
you're just gonna move to the Midwest
yeah
do you remember there was like we're
going into hiding yeah how does nobody
shoot the first time like how do you not
gonna engage in Draft when he has one
arm yeah what about there was The Duda
who was on Contender who has like the uh
like he's got he's got his arm like to
hear yeah like the elbows but not the
arm and then people started being like
dude it's an advantage I was like it's
an advantage everybody
I trained with him at rain yeah he's
really good he was he was a stud he was
tough man yeah he was tough but yeah
there was only one time where like At
first on the surface I was like guys
stop was it was a wrestler from My ASU
uh was it Anthony Robles he won
nationals right you got no legs one leg
right one both legs are yeah there's
either one or both but his upper body
was like a huge huge yeah oh he had one
leg so he had he had one leg and the
other one was like a birth defect or
whatever so but so like At first like
dude he has one leg but then people were
like yo he's really has like the body of
a 170 pound guy fighting guys in 120 oh
because he doesn't have the weight of
his leg Yeah and then I said thought
about I was like oh [ __ ] you're not
being a dick there's actually there
might be some truth to that oh dude
because at first you're like dude he has
an advantages one leg you know I mean
but then I'm like well no he has a style
he grabs wrist controls oh dude he got a
hold of these but he's so much stronger
yeah then I watched some matching like
sure enough like the guy you know you
just see his arms versus the guy like
whoa yeah there is
a stupid yeah there's that guy who has
no legs who's just dominating because
Zuppa he's like a heavyweight but he's
so low yeah he's fighting at like 115
and just you'd get a hold these tiny
guys just snap him yeah how do you shoot
on him I mean like how do you score
points Nick Newell yeah he trained at
ring yeah he's a stud you guys just
convinced me that
having one leg can be an advantage in a
grappling exchange which seems insane
right yeah but when you start taking in
the weight category yeah that's where
you sit there if your upper body's that
of a big boy it's tough man I saw
someone when they were attacking their
ring up an example that uh there was a
guy that said a bench press record for
and it was for away class but he had no
legs and they're like yeah but he has
that body of a 220 guy and he's
competing at 150 or whatever yeah
because you know each leg is like what
you know that's 20 of your body weight
right leg right you know the heaviest
part of the body right your glutes your
hamstrings your quads you don't have
that
I mean I'd rather be weak as [ __ ]
have both legs but yeah at the end of
the day yeah
yeah how much money for one of your legs
oh man no amount of money you're gonna
wait another day put that [ __ ]
artificial Lego now if we could do like
a Robocop no amount of money no no no no
no no no no no
right right well one not just Bezos like
hey man I just want to cut your leg off
how much 200 billion oh my God I'm good
yeah you're like my robotic leg is just
not even you know yeah yeah
yeah I'd have to look in the technology
of the land that's fair if there's
something popping like a bird yeah
I mean they're building like entire
cybernetic humans now so gotta figure
they could probably knock out a leg
that'd be a bummer though
oh I can't wait for this fight it's been
a fun card uh just over there to the
right
see I'm not afraid of it
yeah I'm excited for Charles Oliver and
then I used to be the guy that you know
I picked Charles Oliver to win and
people bring this up and clearly they
didn't listen to my shows before where
you know early on in child deliver his
career he had some quit in him he'd quit
he'd find the easy way out and quit and
they're like oh you're forget about
those days like bro you're talking when
he was eight and eight that now the
guy's confidence he's won what happened
in a row can be built upon you yeah
because I mean look our whole military
is based upon making people who increase
their mind correct diversity like can I
make your mind tougher I I was much more
of a quitter before my earlier in my
career until through adversity and
facing you can build that muscle you
build on it yeah totally can build that
especially foreign
because he could have gave up in the
Michael Chandler fight I mean that could
have been a 10-8 first round he got
wobbled he's getting his ass whooped
that fight goes on longer probably
stopped the fight and then coming on the
second round finishes them yep it's
clearly speed it so when people go
you're forgetting he has some quitting
I'm like you're talking what six years
ago I think he's beat that animal 100 I
agree with you
yeah so people develop and grow 100 they
mature and just like we talk about
people can diminish you know I mean like
yep there's you know an ebb and flow to
this yep it was a growth period and then
there's the decline now the The Knockout
right that sometimes they say when the
lights get bright you know he doesn't
show to his best capabilities but
you have khabib pushing them back there
and [ __ ] yeah
they grew up together like brothers
now according to Josh Thompson who was
in San Jose last week on tour doing
shows he came in the meet and greet you
know I don't want to picture anything
dude let's tell me how my chefs can beat
Charles Oliveira he goes dude every
facet of the game he'll see me you try
it's gonna be much of these fight I was
like dude you're out of your mind I was
like you don't think you're being a
little biased like not at all you just
fight for him all right wow all his Camp
things this is he's gonna slice through
Charles Oliver like butter how look I
don't see it dude how could Charles be
the easiest type for him versus other
guys I don't know now that statement
makes me wonder you know if you sit
there and go hey like he's gonna beat
him everywhere he's better everywhere
than he is yeah but when you say it's
gonna be his easiest fight like well now
you're diminishing how good like that's
the champ you mean the guys that he had
to fight that were number 15 in the
world or were harder than Charles the
guys in the gym are better than the
world champion who's defended the belt
three times yeah that just yeah it's
coach Javier Mendez who's you know Kane
Velazquez look at how relaxed here's the
Javier Mendez said uh Mark Chev is the
best lightweight ever do it he said that
yeah he's the best best lightweight to
ever do it and [ __ ] I guess we'll find
out right now because well he even with
that statement so even if you were out
here and sliced through Charles de
levera he still wouldn't be the best
lightweight to ever do it he still would
have to defend the belt how many times
you know like Charles Oliveira is really
I mean look at the strength of schedule
Charles Olivera's beat you know you go
through the list
khabib obviously to me who's the King of
the Hill yeah
you know 29-0 records kind of hard to
yell yeah I mean I guess the best
biggest pay-per-view events ever for
sure best case scenario here is Charles
starches makashev says something
disrespectful enough into the microphone
that khabib comes out of retirement to
fight Charles that's never happening I
know yeah just because you know kind of
such a man of faith and he promised his
dad who passed away he'd never fight
again it's not the promises to his mom
both of them his mom was like once your
dad you know if your dad were to pass
away you're never fine again so he
promised his mom he promises daddy
wouldn't fight khabib just a big breath
like that was like that was pretty
awesome like he
he wants Islam to win real bad
you had so many you know
so many questions be answered yeah and I
could just be way off I'm just saying I
haven't like I want to see it I'm not
you know I haven't been in the training
room like Josh Thompson Javier Mendez no
I agree with you I I just like from what
I've seen I've seen Charles over from
his actual fights yes but then they
that's what they're saying well he
doesn't show up he's better in the gym
like all right well what's gonna be
different now yeah so you're telling me
that so here's here would be my argument
just to play Devil's Advocate
so when he's been on the undercard and
then he's just been on the main card or
co-main events
he has a hard time with that pressure
and doesn't perform to the top of his
ability what have you guys done that now
he's in the biggest fight of his life
the most amount of attention that he's
ever received and now he's going to make
it work now he's going to be able to
switch it like yeah now you're going to
pull it off it's like I mean great if
you do yeah but just as a person who
likes percentages and I tell you the
odds I mean like hey let's make a bet on
this if we were to bet right now I don't
think most people would bet that you'd
pull that off that's fair but but no
one's ever given any any resistance even
with him supposedly not fighting to his
abilities he's run through everyone
right yeah
he fights to his competition yeah barely
also but it could be more that maybe not
then yeah I agree he's just stepping up
competition but there's one guy that I
I've seen true and tried where he's
passed the test and he's beat the odds
since Charles Oliver and now he's
beating him he's finishing him that was
that was yawn before O'Malley just
unseated him nuts wow I cannot don't dye
your hair like that though right yeah
there we go I had my hair Yeah Christmas
haircut
oh he's just hugging everyone oh they
all dyed their hair for him oh wow
Blonde on Blonde oh man this is so hard
I can't root against him either oh I
can't root against either of them dude
because here's the thing child de lever
you know he's as far as fight years ago
he's long in the tooth yeah my job no
matter what happens he's still gonna
have a chance to be a champ for Charles
you know it's gonna catch up that's true
whether it's tonight two fights or not
it's you know he's at the back nine of
his career Islam's taken one heavy shot
in his entire career and he got knocked
out and he got knocked down aside from
that he's basically taking no damage but
also since Islam got knocked out he
fights super safe he's not gonna be able
to do that against Charles though he's
gonna try he's gonna try he's gonna try
early on yeah because I think if it goes
to decision it's gonna be a boring fight
that's the only like kind of yeah
problem we're gonna have this being a
board fight because matchup don't give a
[ __ ] he's gonna do whatever it takes to
get that belt yeah if it's five rounds
of playing prey which is tough to do
against uh Charles Oliver he'll do it
that's the only way that it's boring is
if Market ship takes him down and
keeps on no I can't wait for this fight
see I I think it's impossible to have a
boring fight if you're Charles Oliver he
just agrees and one of the reasons I
left him as a champ name another champ
who takes chances yeah like hold to get
here
I've never seen guys who have great
exciting fighting styles and all of a
sudden they become the champion I mean
GSP yeah like you he's the main guy I
had that knock on Tyrone Woodley you
know what I mean 100 170 I mean he was a
beast you know I mean murdering guys you
know and also he became the champion I
was like all right well you know it was
one fight after another like wow that
that seemed a little off for him oh that
seemed a little conservative oh you're
not fighting yeah
it's a contractual incentive like
because they you know they get paid so
much more as the champion and so they're
like like look at how Izzy fights now
like Izzy's like oh all right well you
threw 40 punches I'll throw 50. like you
know it's just like just retain the belt
and make many many millions more than I
would if I lost it
but that's why people love Charles
Oliveira that yeah he has all these
performance bonuses you look at
volkanovsky he doesn't fight safe you
know doesn't fight safe we'll go out
there and finish here these other guys
they do man at heavyweight you just have
no choice dude vulcanovski I saw I
watched him at 273 uh we were really
close and he [ __ ] murked Korean
zombie oh yeah it was a tough night for
cranes on me
and then that dude that performance
against Holloway in the third fight was
in unreal and I think he needed that
yeah to win over the fan base because
Max Hall was so beloved yeah he's a fan
favorite and there's like you know it's
kind of controversial he had to have
that yeah fight that was not to move on
to in literally to move on which he did
yeah shout out to bokonowski did you
think that Holloway looked same speed
and everything because to me I watched
like I went and looked at one of his
fights from previous I'm like dude I
think he looks the same it's just
Holloway looked I'm sorry uh volkanovsky
looked I think boganoff's got better
right yeah because remember Max always
coming off that fight who's against uh
was it cater yeah here yair that's right
where you look ridiculous yeah it was
the best night of his life yeah so it
wasn't like a bad version of Max
Halloween that's just how good [ __ ]
okonovsky is
holy [ __ ] I can't [ __ ] believe this
fight's on right now
yeah I just see [ __ ] trouble there
getting finished man which is insane to
say but that's how I see it
uh what am I I'm I'm uh
I'm 50 I'm two out of four now that TJ
blue is God damn children got dominated
I'm not even sure looks a little nervous
oh my God I had a huge parlay that had
TJ Dillashaw won then Olivera Coulda
there's a parlay cinched it yeah but I
mean I but Harleys are tough especially
in UFC part of those are a nightmare
totally that and that you know like the
real uh like right now how do we know
that TJ had an injury
and that weight heavily into that I mean
oh my God I'm not saying that Algerian
still couldn't have won the fight I
didn't get the best version of teeth no
but it was like I wouldn't pick TJ if
you went hey yes one armor yeah nobody's
like oh he's injured no okay never mind
but that's you know but even like legit
betters who you know professional
gamblers they say UFC's the hardest
sport to bet on they don't [ __ ] they
do MLB NBA NFL they do not mess with UFC
it's like it's too much yeah there's too
many variables which is also back to my
point it's the best sport in the world
because there's so many variables we
have no clue what's gonna happen this
fight there's very few times we all can
say and even the fights we think I mean
how many times I've been like oh that's
gonna be one-sided I still to this day
remember sitting there watching Matt
Sarah knock out George Champion yep I
mean I mean if you could tell me like I
mean and I'm telling you there was
nobody outside of hinsel's gym that
thought Matt was knowing I don't care
what it tells me now everybody and I
like Master a lot a great guy but the
night before the fight you're like hey
you want to put your house on this I'm
like on who George yeah no problem yeah
you know what I mean but like I bet on
math no there's no way that night and
guess what nothing that's why Rose did I
said I remember it was ten to one odds
because I specifically remember telling
my wife my now wife I I actually met her
mom that night for the first time but I
remember telling dude I would literally
pull a hundred thousand dollar loan to
put it on GSP just to make 10 grand
that's how sure I am that he's gonna
[ __ ] win and then he lost got knocked
out that's UFC that's why I wrote him
whenever I'm like who he got he's like I
don't know dude he said I don't pick
yeah he's like nobody knows I'm like all
right fair point I like to bet though
you know
actually I did that again in the first
fight with uh uh way and uh Rose yeah I
thought like okay oh this is gonna just
kill her you know what I mean especially
after watching uh Johanna you thought
wait was going to beat the [ __ ] just
Destroyer yeah man as far as actually my
wife was sitting there going I'm telling
you Rosie pulled this off what do you
know about fighting and then I'm sitting
there afterwards like God damn yeah she
according to her in that first fight too
yeah yeah completely slept there yeah
well and then I was two the first time
she fought she did that to me just twice
she's done that so I don't ever bet
against Rosa yeah Joanna Joanna I bet on
her in that fight first one yeah in the
first one here we go boys that's why I
like Charles because if you're gonna
beat Islam you're not gonna beat him by
decision you got to be Reckless and he's
a reckless champion
oh damn Islam's Playing for Keeps and
that's the thing Charles does get hit I
really bet Charles gets dropped is I'm
heavy on his back and then we get a a
finish from Charles later in the rounds
his arms open for left hook though he
Fades back oh right there yeah
oh [ __ ]
all right let's see into Charles guard
here we go this race didn't get dicey
for things you can lock the ankles get a
shoulder guard
I'm telling this I see he's gonna be
throwing junk at this dude down here
where Islam's like [ __ ] this like right
even this oh he's gonna guys he's got
his arm even this is like [ __ ] this
I see the elbows and the non-stop he's
just throwing that's exactly how that's
exactly how I handicapped this fight is
like he's gonna figure out on the ground
and no good and they're gonna end up
standing I can't do it for five rounds
yeah he throws caution in the wind so
I'll take it
Lorenzo Fertitta looking 9 000 years old
back there
just because it's white hair man you
ever see I take a shirt out there like
no he's jacked right yeah oh sorry
diesel Dana lately too yeah Dana's lost
a lot of weight yeah he has that new
doctor is he talking oh I saw it I saw a
thing yeah bro he was telling me about
it kind of freaked the [ __ ] out of me a
little bit you know because he's like
you got 10 and a half years yeah he'll
tell you another month when you're gonna
die I'm like yeah all right but I mean I
mean that's all [ __ ] but at least he
got him on track right yeah bro I mean
yeah Dana's lost like 30 pounds man like
you got people showing like uses my
knees for like a 30 year old I'm like
wow yeah he said dude I heard him
talking about he said that he couldn't
like so he like couldn't tie his shoes
and [ __ ] like he was having like really
serious work in that leg oh great
transition baby
Islam's never been in a fight like this
before no that's not that statement of
just this is to be his easiest fight I'm
sorry I'm sorry I don't like when people
say something I never understood that
even when I go to fight somebody the
whole thing well the guy sucks I'm like
so when you beat him you beat a guy that
sucks like I mean like think about that
mentality like instead I'm like no the
guy I'm fighting with you be true
nice great toss
my uh one of my coaches build your guy
up be truthful yeah you know why does it
have to be set for you to beat them is
that what he needs like like I could be
guys that are actually great yeah is
there anyone you're gonna fight in the
UFC that poses that doesn't pose like
tremendous danger it doesn't exist
because we're all good at something man
looks like the right eye at Charles a
little bit uh beat up there
it's a great uh it's a great juice as
well yeah that's great what's that one
called
or was it the
uchimada right
so again I I do think uh Charles gonna
be down on the cards and get to finish
it's because he throws those Hail Marys
he's so dangerous but and he just
doesn't this is all expected if you're
uh Charles
he's definitely get taken down yeah
like look look at the first round of
that Chandler fight dude he got [ __ ]
pulverized in that fight but he's gonna
have to throw it in that first round you
can't just sit and guard here and like
you're just gonna you know because
that's why you could get [ __ ] up
earlier
look look Charles's guard's dead right
now he can't roll up on the shoulders he
can't pivot on the the back he can't
rotate he's having a way right now he
can't go on attack though it's very
smart of Mach job to use this oh yeah
yeah and then closing the oxy makes you
tired because now you close the guard
when I drive my hips forward it
compresses your diaphragm yeah he's
making Charleston also want to close
your guard there's no there's no danger
of anything from octave yeah man but if
I'm Charles the game plan listen you get
taken down you're being guarded you
gotta fill the [ __ ] kitchen sink at
this dude
across start working up you know
wait so where see like
so right now you I would open my feet
open put it aggressive load like a hip
bump yeah to create frames because right
now I don't need to hold you you're
holding me so what do I need to control
distance well I don't need to control
distance this way if you back away from
me you're doing me a favor right right
so I need to get something between you
and I so I need wedges I need frames so
then an explosion causes movement so I
can explode with a hip bump and then to
keep that space that I created then I
put in a frame so now the frame allows
me now motion so now I can rotate my
hips around and then you got to abandon
the guard you can't have a leg on each
side of the guy's hips right so what I
do is I pull back oh great up kick you
can do go to half guard or even roll
down the turtle control the wrists and
then oh oh
that's around
apparently that new eyesight didn't help
them well you know it's a hard shot to
see here's the toss whoosh
great takedown to be beloved that's
actually the exact same throw through uh
Roy Nelson that's right that's a big boy
yeah that was we we hit the ground hard
yeah yeah and we're always kind of you
know built for not to get toaster yeah
he has a little center of gravity yeah
big legs big butt big belly yeah
he like trained he's like training his
like garages whole career right yeah
well no at the beginning he used to
train in the gym and Chase act and he
trained under uh uh Mark Layman for many
years and he got a brown boat in there
and then then he went with Enzo and IFC
gave him his black belt he's a black
beloved Jujitsu competitor
good wrestler and obviously one hell of
an overhand right yeah he had a great
chin makes for a hell of a fight I could
take a [ __ ] beating him yeah like
very few humans could do you know at the
height of their careers the the security
experiment Rhino strip club in Vegas was
Frank come here and Roy Nelson Jesse
Frank Mir shows up he's like hey guy
see I I see I think I think I failure to
understand each other yeah
I think you've had enough and it's time
to leave see I like Charles Oliver and
the clinch when it's in the middle of
the cage
you land some good elbows but man he's
staying on here
dude here's the other thing is Charles
has not seen a championship round in any
of these fights no because he plays for
keeps trying to get a finish but easy to
say we're all on the same page Islam on
that first round for sure yeah no
hesitation yeah I expect it too I didn't
think Charles didn't come out like a
banshee like he's gonna go through some
fire
some daggers standing on fire to get
this belt here I mean the the the
person who is talking about Islam
running through him that I gave me pause
was for us like if I listened to a video
for Oz didn't he just was like yeah
Islam the only he said something like
the only chance Charles has is XYZ and I
was like damn I disagree but you can't
tell me his son's walking through him no
no I mean he has a fight on his hand no
for sure he won that first round but
he's not walking yeah and I think that
actually
I don't think he's gonna win the second
round but how he's won the first round
yeah I think it's going to go down a
little bit each round
yeah I'll be curious how this looks in
the fourth and fifth round
man Islam I'm sorry Charles throws those
shots looking to just [ __ ] hurt him
every elbow every knee
but to the point Charles keeps losing
the foot battle here on the inside there
you haven't seen Charles lunge in like
this either which is strange his feet
would get very narrow and he comes in he
leaps in and this is the first time
we're actually seeing Islam kind of
engage in her you know striking exchange
yeah and for the comparisons of Islam
and khabib his strikings definitely yeah
no no it could be about an overhand shot
you know what I mean
but he really set it up off the takedown
yeah you were you were terrified of
getting down the bottom yeah and then he
could be the world's greatest I think
could be still the best in the world at
a ground and pound yes
and had the lockdown on the legs that he
had okay there's still things that I
show and teach now that I'm like oh
that's
nice combo and caught him with the right
hook too as he was getting another
mm-hmm
oh you know the Striking is not even in
the same place
was just like I'm gonna walk forward and
be super [ __ ] Reckless make you walk
backwards and eventually he's a
Terminator yeah
and he was just the best in the world to
get you down yep
see you see what I'm saying though how
Charles he'll get a little reckless and
he knows he's gonna get hit but he's
he's going for the yeah he's going oh
[ __ ]
that's that's shoot him right into that
but but that and that's that's again
that's see and most guys don't know he
has a head arm here he's a head arm and
it's tight his face is Grimson but
that's the thing with Charles
if he turns away from me he's okay yeah
oh [ __ ]
wow
wow wow I couldn't have been more wrong
but I thought that was amazing either
real deal yeah that's what makes UFC
great God damn good for him impressed
him yeah look at those guys dude boy
those boys are right he really walked
through them huh yeah
boy he really [ __ ] him up Jesus clouds
way off oh I'm so happy for these
[ __ ] guys Oh I thought it was pretty
competitive until yeah I agree it was a
fight you know it wasn't like an easy it
wasn't like his easiest fight that's for
sure but you know Islam's the again
there's a lot of questions to be
answered how good is Islam he's really
[ __ ] good man wow he's the best 155
in the planet and then Sean how good
sugar he's really [ __ ] good he beat
Peter Young how good is Muhammad he's
[ __ ] good he beat The Undefeated Sean
Brady you know what I'm saying dude I'm
good how good is uh uh Darius pretty
[ __ ] good how good is Al Jermaine
even though you know uh TJ had one
shoulder pretty [ __ ] good dude so
there's a lot of questions answered yeah
Ali Abdel was he had a [ __ ] great
night tonight all his guys won yeah all
is good yeah I love Ollie he's good
people dude Charles Oliver is a good
dude
I should try to do this jump knee around
oh that's what makes him great that's
such a risk again that's why you love
them but at a certain level it catches
up with you well see it's not Islam
though they they let him sit on his back
and recover
Islam's like nope I'm gonna strangle you
yeah he jumped in where I thought would
be a dangerous thing actually was a
benefit immediately jumped in past the
half guard locked up to your head and
arm and then Kenny not rotate to the
left there he should have he should have
punched his arm straight jump to his
knees right yeah yeah oh you can escape
that oh yeah yeah yeah it's a really
good Escape yeah yeah matter of fact
yeah
this way and then yeah so what happens
is you're heading on to me right you're
on the side of your arms here yeah I'm
going to throw my legs away from you and
punch and go to my knees if you hold on
you're getting rolled over to your back
and a lot of guys but it's the natural
reaction turned into it makes it yeah it
work you go away I go way away because
you're on this side yeah and actually
knowing that defense how I kind of beat
guys that know it is I'll bait them to
grab my legs so I'll grab her head and
arm and give him my leg and they'll lock
half guard and then you're screwed
because then you lost your defense your
defense will throw your legs away from
me so sometimes I'll entice a person's
response to grab my leg it's like well
now you just got rid of your explosion
your hips yeah so yeah so you want to
run your feet away from me and like go
away go away give me your back
essentially the success rate on that
defensive super hot super hot if you
explode hard you know what you're doing
unless this guy's like really nice
it's actually the only defensive works
on me because ever since I got flipped
off in a fight one time I went and like
mastered the head and arm like I became
obsessed with it and now people like oh
answer the telephone like it won't work
on me you know okay answer the phone go
ahead you know I'll let them hold their
ear hold their leg go ahead get in
position because the way I choke it
sideways so you can't block that part so
it doesn't matter so I still put you to
sleep so but the defensive works on me
is if you throw your legs and you roll
away from me and roll to your knees I
let go because I know that if I keep
holding on I'm going for it's like a fat
man roll holding a guy by the waist and
him rolling to his hip I'm gonna go over
it's a Hail Mary but you're getting out
of it yeah you might especially Islam
before I can get your backpack you're
gonna be in Turtle positions yeah this
guy but you're not straight guys should
let go and float into a referee yes
Turtle position top you know every time
especially for the high level guy and
izon would have done that but you're not
getting finished and he's not you know
marrying around the ring with that kid
in the back look how [ __ ] happy he is
dude like he just came through for for
their like now DC has to be on biased
too but he's happy as [ __ ] dude look at
that dude
these [ __ ] knew this [ __ ] was
coming from like they they called this
how long ago
well I mean since since he entered the
UFC so people retire and then he'll get
it what a cool moment
who caught him with the head kick I
forgot they uh clipped him I think it
was actually a punch straight right hand
right yeah and then that was the guy he
lost the next one yeah it was um and he
got a long time ago since then he fought
pretty safe yeah now I'll tell you the
most impressive thing about Islam and
I'll count two grand now which sucks but
uh most the most impressive thing about
Islam is uh his striking I think that
was I mean a grappling with you he's
[ __ ] good at and this mission is
ridiculous his striking is no punk no
dude yeah yeah I mean he he got that
fish because of that shot right there
yeah or or great conversations he flows
he never once threw one shot at a time
it was always a combinations look at
that one two you want to know you wanna
know what what year would you guess he
lost
uh we're doing 2022 he lost in two on uh
16 15. yeah
15. yeah and since then he lost October
almost exactly exactly seven you'll see
the and hopefully this is for Sean Brady
you'll see the guys take losses in the
career and it was the perfect time for
it and it will never happen again bro
okay so this guy knocked out is a moga
chef in his next fight he lost my
decision next one he lost by knockout
next one he lost by decision next one no
contest next one lost next one yeah he's
lost every fight he just comes since
he's knocked out UFC great he just
caught him I mean if you're still anyway
in the UFC like it doesn't if you're a
UFC level and we can catch him yeah
let's know if he calls anybody out you
know ask Mike I am definitely 100 gonna
go watch that speech later
how happy is and Sean's
could be so [ __ ] happy yeah I won't
see Alger means too
me too
I don't know if I trust that down with
the glasses in the back right
what's what's the little cute Hezbollah
with the most submissions this belt is
for my coach could be
so the goal is to get the submission to
prove yeah wow child did a short the
other day where he has a son on his lap
and he's like he's all this is my son
he's like look at uh selfishly I'm using
him as a prop you know I'm just just
kind of self-aggrandizing myself also in
totally unrelated news Hezbollah is
going to be an islamakashev's shoulder
corner
foreign
strangling him dude but but yeah I I got
it I mean
you know how it is oh that's a fight
right look vocal honestly not not that
small
right after you see a guy whip someone's
ass though you're always like oh he's
gonna win every other fight forever but
I I will the way he beat Charles though
that was that was nuts that was
impressive that's gonna be a tough fight
the Striking is really really high level
yeah well-rounded fighter everywhere I
mean where's his weakness yeah and
volcanowski I've never like I've never
seen has anybody ever put volcanovsky on
his back uh he got knocked down right
taken down
Australia
wow I don't think I don't think Mike
Jeff gives a flying [ __ ]
see the shortcuts I always I always like
how stressed out the the the translators
are it's a tough job yeah dude because
in the when the guy just goes nuts on
the mic and he has to recap it they have
to try to yeah remember the 20 yeah they
just sum it up like what's he saying
he's like he's he said he had a good
night yeah he said thank you so much for
30 minutes
[Music]
poor Charles yeah and the poor guys that
dyed all the hair blonde Islam had a lot
more to lose look at the guy picking his
nose come on dude that's commitment you
know I mean because everybody else could
just dump a t-shirt yeah yeah who would
you have no not him but we know who you
were going for
man Charles looks pretty he looks sad
but promises he will get this fight
this fight I want to see it
he you know you have to win another one
you know at 55 and there's changing of a
guard it's just you know I thought the
belt was gonna it was me I don't I don't
think you're gonna see like a Jon Jones
or is he run or tomorrow run at 55.
after seeing Islam do that to Charles
with his style he could hold that belt
for a while dude you know what you know
what and I don't see Charles just from
what I saw right there his defense as
far as the offensive output his strike I
thought his Reach In His Hands would be
a little bit more of a problem
it wasn't a problem it was one-sided in
the stand-up even though it was like not
a one-sided fight but the stand-up
itself wasn't close I think they fight
nine times out of ten Charles pulls one
of them off just because 90 time I mean
much of his possible get knocked out by
a guy who has a loser record right so
yeah you're right they fight nine out of
ten times could you still catch them
yeah yeah but if we want to bet on the
next fight I'm like after what I just
saw
all day there's no way he's just the
combinations he was throwing the angles
stepping back his position is balanced
he's just too sound yeah
I had Charles and you know I was like
I'm not ready to co-sign a mock Jeff and
be like oh you're wrong on the pick like
yeah dude I had I just I didn't believe
the hype yet I wanted to see it and I
see it there it is yeah I'm always late
yeah yeah when it comes to picking
people I've always been notoriously late
like you got to convince me you know I
mean I don't care about training
partners are biased yeah I don't care
coaches or buyers coaches are biased
dude I mean like I don't want to hear
what you did in the gym you know what I
mean because because for every time that
comes true it's been 10 times I agree
we've seen 20 times it's like no it's
not real yeah I mean guys just think too
highly if they're trying but the only
guy that I really co-sign is uh bo
nickel as far as easy yeah I'm like yeah
I'll take it yeah I'll take that back
that might be the only time my life
happens me too dude imagine super early
if if I'm Dana right now I'm gonna just
jump inside his brain here's what he's
thinking he's like who can we feed to
Conor to set up a Conor [ __ ] Islam
fight at 55. he's getting like Tony
Ferguson feed him Tony
and get him in there and now you got
khabib Conor part two o'clock coming off
yeah but kind of duster that straight
left hand man Connor is still there dude
yeah this card lift up to the hype yes
that's for sure yeah I appreciate you
guys coming Jesse we've won this for a
long time I think we're doing it next
weekend we're doing next Saturday we
have the Jake Paul Anderson Silva fight
are you doing next weekend too yeah you
bet your sweet ass look at that dude
yeah yeah I'm gonna call it or go to it
so you guys tell me yeah let's come on
yeah yeah we're doing this for the Jake
Paul fight and he also got Arnold Allen
and Calvin cater Arnold Allen's another
guy I'm high on he's another guy
nothing's a real deal yeah I'll go watch
it I don't like that and I love Arnold
Allen's a real deal his dad with a was a
a strong man in the UK wow so he comes
from that background yeah and probably
lifts that way too which that translates
really great in MMA yeah he's Arnold
Allen's a bodybuilding not so much he's
a problem yeah
strong man [ __ ] I've done that yeah yeah
does that Bella do a lot monster but we
will see you guys next week that is on
the 29th of October 27th 28th I'm in
Calgary come get some we added show on
Friday in Calgary at the rooftop
downtown Calgary's next Thursday Friday
Thursday is almost sold out so get
tickets for Friday then after that I am
in San Antonio November 3rd through the
5th I'll be at that one LOL Jesse will
be there the week after that I'm in
Houston and then Milwaukee go get you
some thinkboy.com thanks tune in Jessie
on fire Frank Mayer love you guys we'll
see you guys next week thanks for tuning
in we're out